Thank you for listening to The Rest Is History. For weekly bonus episodes, ad-free listening, early access to series, and membership of our much-loved chat community, go to therestishistory.com and join the club. That is therestishistory.com. A great liner, stealing through the vast loneliness of the Atlantic, the sky jewelled with myriads of stars overhead, and a thin little wind blowing cold and even colder straight from the frozen ice fields, tapping its warning of approaching danger on the cosily shuttered portholes of the cabins, causing the lookout man to strain his eyes anxiously into the gloom. Inside this floating palace, warmth, lights and music, the flutter of cards, the hum of voices, the gay lilt of a German waltz, the unheeding sounds of a small world bent on pleasure then disaster swift and overwhelming
感谢您收听《历史的余味》（The Rest Is History）。如需收听每周的额外剧集、享受无广告体验、抢先观看系列节目并加入我们备受喜爱的聊天社区，请访问 therestishistory.com 加入俱乐部。网址是 therestishistory.com。一艘宏伟的远洋客轮，悄然穿行在广袤而寂寥的大西洋上，头顶是缀满繁星的苍穹，一阵阵寒风从冰封的冰原吹来，愈发凛冽，敲打着客舱舒适而紧闭的舷窗，发出危险临近的警示，令瞭望员焦虑地瞪大双眼，凝视着黑暗。在这座漂浮的宫殿里，温暖、灯光与音乐交织，纸牌翻动的声音、人们的低语、德国华尔兹轻快的旋律，这个沉浸在享乐中的小世界对即将到来的毁灭一无所知，随后，灾难迅速而猛烈地降临。
turning all into darkness and chaos the laughing voices changed into shuddering wails of despair a story of horror unparalleled in the annals of the sea. So that Dominic was lingerie magnate Lucy Lady Duff Gordon writing in 1932. So that's 20 years after the disaster that was the sinking of the Titanic. She obviously survived or else she wouldn't have been writing that in circumstances that we will be exploring in today's episode, which is looking at the incredible drama of how the Titanic came to sink. And I use the word drama advisedly because it's often been pointed out that the length of time it took from the hitting of the iceberg to the final plunging of the Titanic down to the bottom of the Atlantic was about two hours and 40 minutes, which is the average time
将一切化为黑暗与混乱，欢声笑语变成了令人战栗的绝望哀号，这是航海史上前所未有的恐怖故事。这是内衣大亨露西·达夫·戈登夫人（Lucy Lady Duff Gordon）于1932年写下的文字。那是在泰坦尼克号沉没灾难发生20年后。她显然幸存了下来，否则她就不会在那种情况下写下这些，我们将在今天的节目中探讨这些细节，回顾泰坦尼克号沉没过程中的惊人戏剧性。我慎重地使用了“戏剧性”这个词，因为人们常指出，从撞上冰山到泰坦尼克号最终沉入大西洋底，大约耗时两小时四十分钟，这正是
of a West End play. So it's kind of like a performance at the theatre. It's been retold many, many times. It has that quality of an awful drama, doesn't it? It absolutely does. I think partly because, as with many times when you go to the theatre, you know the ending. So there can be few people who approach this story without, you know,
一部西区戏剧的平均时长。所以这就像是一场剧院演出。它被讲述过很多很多次。它确实有一种可怕戏剧的特质，不是吗？确实如此。我想部分原因在于，就像去剧院看戏一样，你已经知道了结局。所以很少有人在接触这个故事时，
knowing what's going to happen, without knowing that the Titanic is going to sink. But I think it means that any narrative of it, as is no different, is charged with a kind of dramatic irony from the beginning, that it's the story of a lot of people who think everything is going to be all right, who have no idea what is coming. I mean, that's true to some degree of all history. Well, more than all right.
不知道会发生什么，不知道泰坦尼克号最终会沉没。但我认为这意味着，关于它的任何叙述，从一开始就充满了某种戏剧性的反讽，这是一个关于许多人以为一切都会好起来，却对即将到来的灾难一无所知的故事。我的意思是，某种程度上所有历史都是如此。嗯，不仅仅是“好起来”。
I mean, they think it's heaven, don't they? I mean, as in that passage we just read, it's... Yes. Yeah, absolutely. German waltzes and cards and all kinds of things. The last episode where we were talking about the passengers on the last night of their voyage, we had a quotation from a guy called Jack Thayer who said, it was a night when you felt wonderful to be alive
我的意思是，他们以为那是天堂，不是吗？就像我们刚才读到的那段话……是的。没错，绝对是。德国华尔兹、纸牌游戏等等。在上一集我们谈到乘客们航行最后一晚时，引用了杰克·塞耶（Jack Thayer）的话，他说，那是一个让你觉得活着真好的夜晚。
because the sailing conditions have been so good because they're in this great floating palace. He had a quotation from a guy called Jack Thayer who said, it was a night when you felt wonderful to be alive. Yeah. Because the sailing conditions have been so good because they're in this great floating palace. Stars ablaze overhead. And the calmness of the conditions is something that people should absolutely bear in mind. That it's very, very cold and very, very calm. Yeah. So in the last episode, the Titanic plunging towards an iceberg basically swerves and that swerve is fatal because the bottom edge the serrated edge of the iceberg kind of grinds along the side of the of the ship
因为航行条件非常好，因为他们身处这座宏伟的漂浮宫殿中。他引用了杰克·塞耶的话，他说，那是一个让你觉得活着真好的夜晚。是的。因为航行条件非常好，因为他们身处这座宏伟的漂浮宫殿中。头顶繁星闪烁。这种平静的条件是人们绝对应该记住的。天气非常、非常冷，也非常、非常平静。是的。所以在上一集，泰坦尼克号冲向冰山时基本转向了，而那个转向是致命的，因为冰山的底部边缘，那种锯齿状的边缘，沿着船身摩擦，
does exactly and opens it up yes yes exactly right and actually the thing that everybody really talks about is the sound so in walter lord's book a night to remember and indeed in the other book that we've been talking about a lot richard davenport Hines' book, Titanic Lives, both of those writers have lots and lots of examples of the different ways in which people described the sound. So one of the lookouts said it was a grinding sound on the bottom. Another lookout, a grating sound, like a ship running up on gravel, a crushing noise. And lots of the passengers said it was a sort of clattering. It was the sound of going over marbles. But it's not a particularly...
确实如此，并划开了船体。是的，完全正确。其实大家谈论最多的还是声音。在沃尔特·洛德（Walter Lord）的《那一夜》（A Night to Remember）一书中，以及我们谈论很多的理查德·达文波特-海恩斯（Richard Davenport-Hines）的《泰坦尼克号人生》（Titanic Lives）一书中，这两位作者都列举了许多人们描述那种声音的不同方式。一位瞭望员说那是底部传来的磨擦声。另一位瞭望员说是刺耳的摩擦声，就像船在砾石上行驶，一种破碎的噪音。许多乘客说那是一种咔哒声。就像走在弹珠上的声音。但这并不是特别……
Oh my God, we're sinking. No, not at all. You get strange sounds on ships at sea. You do indeed. You do indeed. But of course, one guy who I guess is a bit twitchy is William Murdoch, who is effectively the man in charge. So Edward Smith has retired. Yes. He is first officer and he knows they must have hit. And he also knows that in this situation, the Titanic has been built with these various kind of watertight compartments along
“天哪，我们要沉了。”不，完全不是。在海上航行时，你会听到各种奇怪的声音。确实如此。确实如此。但当然，有一个人我想他有点紧张，那就是威廉·默多克（William Murdoch），他实际上是负责人。因为爱德华·史密斯（Edward Smith）已经休息了。是的。他是大副，他知道他们肯定撞上了。他也知道在这种情况下，泰坦尼克号建造了各种防水隔舱，沿着
the side, hasn't it? 16 of them, Tom. 16 of them. Yes. And there's a kind of switch, isn't there, that he presses? Automatic doors. Yeah. And they go down presumably to inspect the damage. Yeah, that's right. So listeners who've been with us since the beginning of this series will recall that they have the most elaborate safety features of any ship yet built. They have these, as you said, these different watertight compartments separated by bulkheads, but the bulkheads don't go right to the very top of the ship. No, they go up about 14 feet, don't they? And the way it works is if you hit something head-on,
船身，不是吗？有16个，汤姆。16个。是的。有一个开关，对吧，他按下了那个开关？自动门。是的。他们大概下去检查损坏情况了。是的，没错。所以从本系列节目开始就一直收听的听众会记得，他们拥有当时建造的任何船只中最精密的各种安全设施。正如你所说，他们有这些由舱壁隔开的防水隔舱，但舱壁并没有延伸到船的最顶部。不，它们大约有14英尺高，对吧？它的工作原理是，如果你正面撞上什么东西，
the first four of those compartments can be flooded, and actually it'll be fine. You'll be able to keep going. Because the rest will be buoyed by the air in the watertight compartments. Similarly, if something hits you broadside, so in the centre of the ship, two of those compartments can be flooded, and it's fine.
前四个隔舱可能会进水，但其实没关系。你仍然可以继续航行。因为其余部分会被防水隔舱里的空气浮力支撑住。同样，如果侧面撞击，也就是在船的中心，两个隔舱进水，也没问题。
What will not be fine is if the first six are all flooded. Because it will then rise up over the... Exactly. The ship will start tipping, and it'll go over the top of the bulkheads, into the next one, the next one, the next one. And actually in the film, people who've seen the James Cameron film, which we'll be talking about in the next episode, there's a scene when this is brilliantly explained
但如果前六个隔舱都进水，那就麻烦了。因为它会漫过……没错。船会开始倾斜，水会漫过舱壁，进入下一个，再下一个，再下一个。其实在电影里，看过詹姆斯·卡梅隆电影的人（我们下一集会谈到）会记得，当这一幕被精彩地解释时，
by Thomas Andrews, the designer, after the iceberg is hit. He gets out a sort of a chart. Yeah, it's one of the great moments in the film. Anyway, we will come to that. So this is coming. They know that this will be the case. But actually, what's happened in the meantime is that the passengers, some of them have heard this noise.
由设计师托马斯·安德鲁斯（Thomas Andrews）在撞上冰山后解释。他拿出一张图表。是的，这是电影中最伟大的时刻之一。总之，我们会谈到这一点。所以灾难即将来临。他们知道会是这样。但实际上，与此同时发生的事情是，乘客们，有些人听到了这个噪音。
So a lot of the passengers, of course, are asleep, have gone to bed. It's 1140. But there are people who say, oh, gosh, what's that? And generally what happens, the survivors say things like, we felt a rip, we felt a twist, a heave of the engines, one of them says, and a more than obvious dancing motion of the mattress that I was sitting on, a rumbling scraping noise, all these things. And almost without exception, the stewards, as is their job, say...
所以很多乘客当然在睡觉，已经上床了。当时是11点40分。但有些人说，哦，天哪，那是什么？通常发生的情况是，幸存者说的话类似于：我们感觉到一阵撕裂，感觉到一阵扭曲，引擎的一阵颠簸，其中一人说，还有我坐的床垫出现了明显的晃动，一种隆隆的刮擦声，所有这些。几乎无一例外，乘务员们按照他们的职责说……
It's all going to be fine. Oh, don't worry, it'll be fine. Not least because, of course, they think it will be fine. They think it's just, as you said, Tom, it's a bit like when you're on a plane. Everyone knows that. There's a sort of strange noise and you think, oh my God. But actually, it's completely fine. I mean, of course, also, what happens afterwards, though, is that there isn't a noise.
“一切都会好起来的。哦，别担心，没事的。”这不仅是因为他们确实认为会没事。他们认为这就像你坐飞机一样，汤姆，正如你所说。每个人都知道。有一种奇怪的噪音，你会想，哦，天哪。但实际上，完全没事。我的意思是，当然，后来发生的事情是，没有声音了。
So the Titanic is not moving. Yes. And anyone who's been on a train at night, you can always tell when you come into a platform because suddenly the train is not moving and there is a silence. Yeah. And the silence in a way can be very loud. Yes. So that is also something.
所以泰坦尼克号不动了。是的。任何在晚上坐过火车的人都知道，当你进入站台时，你会感觉到火车突然不动了，周围一片寂静。是的。而那种寂静在某种程度上可以是非常震耳欲聋的。是的。所以这也是一回事。
So the stewards are going around and saying, we'll be on our way very soon. But as it is, it is just this great ship is motionless now on this very, very still sea. But actually stopping the ship, Tom, initially is very noisy. And actually one of the things that the survivors remember is that initial cacophony. So what happens is that on deck steam when you stop the engine steam starts roaring off so people have gone up on deck to investigate are actually deafened by the sound of the steam kind of pouring out and are slightly worried about it and then as you say you have this long kind of dead silence now at this point people are already people have gone down to the mail room, and the mail room is one of the
所以乘务员们到处说，我们很快就会继续航行。但事实上，这艘伟大的船现在在这片非常、非常平静的海面上静止不动了。但实际上，让船停下来，汤姆，最初是非常吵的。事实上，幸存者们记得的一件事就是最初的那种嘈杂声。发生的情况是，当引擎停止时，甲板上的蒸汽开始呼啸而出，所以那些上甲板查看情况的人实际上被蒸汽喷出的声音震聋了，并对此感到有些担忧，然后正如你所说，你现在有了这种漫长的死寂。此时，人们已经下到了邮政室，而邮政室是
first places that gets really flooded. So it's getting ankle deep in water. And this is not a good sign. No. And as soon as people realize that's happening, this is kind of serious. Meanwhile, the stewards are going around saying to people, gosh, we might have run into something worst case scenario i mean one says to lady duff gordon who you quoted at the beginning wrap up warmly for you may have a little trip for an hour or so in one of our lifeboats and actually lady duff gordon says later you know if it hadn't been for this ill-advised reticence hundreds more lives would have been saved now of course the issue is i mean we'll get onto the knife boats in a second because lots of people will be thinking of this already, I imagine, when they're listening.
第一批真正被淹没的地方之一。所以水已经没过脚踝了。这不是个好兆头。不。一旦人们意识到这一点，情况就变得严重了。与此同时，乘务员们到处对人们说，天哪，我们可能撞到了什么东西，最坏的情况。我的意思是，有人对达夫·戈登夫人（你在开头引用的那位）说：“穿暖和点，你可能要在救生艇里待上一小时左右。”事实上，达夫·戈登夫人后来写道，你知道，如果不是因为这种不明智的沉默，本可以挽救数百人的生命。当然，问题在于，我的意思是，我们马上会谈到救生艇，因为我想很多人在听的时候已经在想这个问题了。
One of the issues is there are not enough light boats for the numbers of people. So even if the stewards had gone around saying to everybody, panic, quick, get up on deck, that would not necessarily, I mean, maybe more people would have been saved but it would have created all kinds of problems once people realized there weren't enough lifeboats but also i mean they do have to ensure that there isn't a stampede of course they do yes so they they can't really afford to to rush around you know all hands on deck help we're all going to sink no no no and i guess at this point still they don't think that no because it's still in the first five ten minutes after the encounter with the iceberg so you know it's not yet
其中一个问题是救生艇的数量不足以容纳所有人。所以即使乘务员们到处说，“快逃命，快上甲板”，那也不一定……我的意思是，也许更多人能获救，但这会引发各种问题，一旦人们意识到救生艇不够用。但我也认为，他们必须确保不会发生踩踏事件，当然他们必须这样做。是的，所以他们真的不能到处乱跑说，“全体甲板集合，救命，我们要沉了”，不，不，不。我想此时他们仍然不认为会沉没，因为这还是撞上冰山后的前五到十分钟，所以你知道，还不是
certain the millionaires in particular seem to have been reasonably insouciant so there's a guy from a couple of episodes ago charles hayes from canada's grand trunk railroad he says to somebody he says to a chemical manufacturer you cannot sink this boat no matter what we've struck she is good for eight or ten hours but dominic that chemical manufacturer i mean he has noted that the boat is starting to list yes he's kind of saying well this is yeah shouldn't be doing this he says exactly that is this shouldn't be happening well particularly because the water is so calm so the thing is reading up on this i was reminded so often of you know when you take any form of kind of mass transit it could be you mentioned a train but of course a plane is the more obvious
确定的。百万富翁们似乎相当漫不经心。几集前提到过一个人，来自加拿大格兰特铁路公司的查尔斯·海斯（Charles Hayes），他对某人说，他对一位化学制造商说：“无论我们撞上了什么，你都无法让这艘船沉没。她还能航行八到十个小时。”但多米尼克，那位化学制造商，我的意思是，他注意到船开始倾斜了。是的，他有点说，“嗯，这……不应该这样。”他说的正是，“这不应该发生。”嗯，特别是因为水面如此平静。所以读到这些时，我经常想起，你知道，当你乘坐任何形式的公共交通工具时，你提到了火车，但飞机当然是更明显的
example i would say you put yourself in the hands of this great bureaucracy that you don't really understand the workings of it. And, you know, you shuffle along in your queue when told to, you behave exactly as ordered. You don't generally be the person who makes a fuss and starts shouting. Not just because you're kicked off the plane. But also particularly not if you're an Edwardian gentleman. Exactly, exactly. Where kind of stiffness and a refusal to panic is part of the marker of your class. Absolutely.
例子，我想说，你把自己交给了这个你并不真正了解其运作方式的庞大官僚机构。而且，你知道，当被告知时，你会在队列中挪动，你表现得完全像被命令的那样。你通常不会成为那个大惊小怪、开始大喊大叫的人。不仅是因为你会被赶下飞机。而且特别是如果你是一位爱德华时代的绅士。没错，没错。那种僵硬和拒绝恐慌是你们阶层的标志。绝对是。
So the millionaires, it has to be said, behave well. They do and they die. Reading this story, Tom, I mean, not to sort of give too much of a spoiler, I was thinking all the time, what would I have done in this situation? And I know what I'd have done. I'd be dead because I'd be too embarrassed to make a fuss. You know, even if people in my family were saying, go and say something, I'd say, no, I'd rather die than stand out in some way and say the wrong or do the wrong thing.
所以百万富翁们，必须说，表现得很好。他们确实表现得很好，然后他们死了。读这个故事，汤姆，我的意思是，不是为了剧透太多，我一直在想，在这种情况下我会做什么？我知道我会做什么。我会死，因为我会太尴尬而不敢大惊小怪。你知道，即使我家人说，“去说点什么”，我也会说，“不，我宁愿死也不愿以某种方式引人注目，说错话或做错事。”
And clearly lots of people, they're paralyzed, aren't they? By uncertainty, by passivity, by obedience, by deference, by conformity, all of these kinds of things. And the people who often survive, Richard Davenport Hines has a good example of a widow. She's called Emma Bucknell. She's a first-class passenger. You get the impression she's a sort of a bolshie bossy woman or somebody who would be described as being like that by patronizing men. And the stewards say to her, don't worry's fine go back to your cabin and she doesn't she dresses up and she goes out and there's a woman who says oh we won't have hit an iceberg and mrs button is like picking up pieces of ice yeah and saying to her look at this it's a bloody big bit of ice
显然很多人都被瘫痪了，不是吗？被不确定性、被被动、被服从、被顺从、被从众，所有这些东西。而那些幸存下来的人，理查德·达文波特-海恩斯有一个关于一位寡妇的好例子。她叫艾玛·巴克内尔（Emma Bucknell）。她是一位头等舱乘客。你给人的印象是她是一个有点倔强、爱发号施令的女人，或者会被那些傲慢的男人描述成那样的人。乘务员对她说：“别担心，没事，回你的客舱去。”但她没有，她穿好衣服走出来，有个女人说：“哦，我们不可能撞上冰山。”巴克内尔夫人捡起冰块，对她说：“看看这个，这是一大块血淋淋的冰。”
we've obviously hit an iceberg and being difficult saves you yeah and being a good person kills you i would say and we're now kind of 10 minutes after the iceberg yes and people are already starting to prepare for the possibility that they may have to get in lifeboats yeah and evacuate the ship yes so lady duff gordon who we have mentioned yes she has a silk kimono and a squirrel coat some a coat made of squirrels yeah i guess red squirrels because there wouldn't have been gray squirrels in britain by that point no and madeline aster yeah so the teenage bride of uh of jack aster yeah she is in a black coat with sable trim a diamond necklace and fur muff that's what i'd wear on a lifeboat so they're
“我们显然撞上了一座冰山。”而这种“难搞”救了她的命。是的，做一个好人反而会害死你，我想是这样。我们现在距离撞上冰山大约10分钟了。是的，人们已经开始准备可能需要进入救生艇，并撤离船只。是的。所以达夫·戈登夫人，我们提到过，是的，她穿着丝绸和服和一件松鼠皮大衣，用松鼠做的外套。是的，我想是红松鼠，因为那时英国还没有灰松鼠。没有。还有玛德琳·阿斯特（Madeleine Astor），是的，杰克·阿斯特（Jack Astor）的十几岁新娘，是的，她穿着一件带黑貂皮镶边的黑色大衣，戴着钻石项链和毛皮暖手筒。这就是我会穿在救生艇上的东西。所以她们
going to look good yeah they're going to look good on the lifeboats. And Henry Widener, this is where he picks up his copy of Bacon's Essays, the 1598. Oh, yes. Which Robert Davenport Hines quotes this. A fellow bibliophile has called this the most touching, most pathetic, with all the most glorious incident in the romance of book collecting. Oh, that's nice, isn't it? So we've got muffs and we've got… Bacon.
看起来会很漂亮。是的，她们在救生艇上会看起来很漂亮。还有亨利·怀德纳（Henry Widener），这就是他拿起他的《培根随笔集》（Bacon's Essays，1598年版）的地方。哦，是的。罗伯特·达文波特-海恩斯引用了这一点。一位书友称这是藏书浪漫史中最感人、最可怜，同时也最光荣的事件。哦，那真不错，不是吗？所以我们有暖手筒，还有……培根。
We've got bacon. All the ingredients for an evening, actually. So the millionaires are starting to... They're not panicking, but they are putting on their muffs and their squirrel coats, picking up their 16th century first editions. Meanwhile, your hero, Captain Smith,'s literally been a sleep on watch. What's he up to? So the first thing he does, he doesn't panic.
我们有培根。其实是一个晚上的所有要素。所以百万富翁们开始……他们没有恐慌，但他们穿上了暖手筒和松鼠皮大衣，拿起了他们的16世纪初版书。与此同时，你的英雄，史密斯船长，字面上一直在值班时睡觉。他在干什么？所以他做的第一件事，他没有恐慌。
He goes to the Marconi cabin. He says to the operators, we've hit an iceberg. You may well need to send messages preparing help. I will inspect the damage and then I will let you know. And Ismay pops up as well, doesn't he? Wearing slippers. He's wearing slippers and he's got his pyjamas underneath his trousers. Yes. And his moustache is looking very droopy by this point.
他去了马可尼无线电室。他对操作员说：“我们撞上了一座冰山。你们很可能需要发送信息请求援助。我去检查损坏情况，然后我会通知你们。”伊斯梅（Ismay）也出现了，不是吗？穿着拖鞋。他穿着拖鞋，裤子里面穿着睡衣。是的。此时他的胡子看起来很垂头丧气。
Thomas Andrews, the designer who we talked about many moons ago when we were talking about the ship being mailed in Belfast. Thomas Andrews goes with Smith on a tour of the ship and people who've seen the film again will remember this. It's a great moment and he kind of realises the ship is people who've seen the film again will remember this it's a great moment and he kind of realizes the ship is going to sink and ismay is saying i mean in the film but also i think in reality is saying but it can't you know it's unsinkable yeah she's made of iron so i assure you she can and she will yes it is a mathematical certainty so what they have done is they've gone down and they see straight away the six forward compartments have been breached the iceberg has ripped you described it's like a can opener didn't you yeah the iceberg has basically torn a hole along the side of six of these compartments so below the water line and
托马斯·安德鲁斯，我们几个月前谈论这艘船在贝尔法斯特建造时谈到的设计师。托马斯·安德鲁斯和史密斯一起巡视了船只，看过电影的人会记得这一点。这是一个伟大的时刻，他意识到船……看过电影的人会记得这一点，这是一个伟大的时刻，他意识到船要沉了，而伊斯梅在说——电影里是这样，但我认为现实中也是——在说：“但这不可能，你知道，它是永不沉没的。”是的，它是铁做的。所以我向你保证，它能，而且它会。是的，这是一个数学上的必然。所以他们所做的是，他们下去了，他们立刻看到前六个隔舱已经被冲破了，冰山已经撕裂了，你描述过，就像开罐器，不是吗？是的，冰山基本上沿着这六个隔舱的侧面撕开了一个洞，在吃水线以下，并且
it is clear to andrews immediately that it's all over that it is game over the water is pouring in and the water will rise up over the bulkheads and one by one the compartments will be flooded. And he says, and again this is in the film, he says explicitly, we have at most two hours. And there is this sort of moment which the film captures perfectly, which undoubtedly happened in real life, when they realise there are not enough lifeboats.
安德鲁斯立刻清楚一切都结束了，游戏结束了。水正在涌入，水会漫过舱壁，隔舱会一个接一个地被淹没。他说，同样，这在电影里也有，他明确表示：“我们最多还有两个小时。”电影完美地捕捉到了那一刻，这无疑在现实生活中也发生了，当他们意识到救生艇不够用时。
A lot of people are going to die. Unless, of course, Dominic, they can get help from other ships. Help straight away, yes. So this is what Smith then does, isn't it? Yeah, and Smith and actually all the officers, by and large, keep their cool, don't they? Well, they would do. I mean, they're British officers.
很多人会死。除非，当然，多米尼克，他们能从其他船只那里得到帮助。立刻得到帮助，是的。所以这就是史密斯接下来要做的，不是吗？是的，史密斯和所有的军官，大体上都保持冷静，不是吗？嗯，他们会这样做的。我的意思是，他们是英国军官。
One would expect that, the very idea that they wouldn't. Well, I mean, Tom, when we get to our final episode and we talk about reactions to it i mean british newspapers took enormous pride in this attack because it went down well a good death they said people people behaved absolutely splendidly and what a what a tremendous reflection on britain this is because they do they do keep their calm so he goes off and he transmits cqd which is the international call for help yes and the first call goes out quarter past midnight the first distress call cq is uh the marconi code for all stations and d indicates an emergency call exactly and it is known slang wise has come quick danger yeah so sos does exist SOS has only been brought in four years earlier.
人们会期待那样，那种他们不会那样做的想法。嗯，我的意思是，汤姆，当我们进入最后一集谈论对此的反应时，我的意思是，英国报纸对这次袭击感到无比自豪，因为这表现得很好，他们说这是一种“好的死亡”，人们表现得非常出色，这对英国来说是一个多么巨大的反思，因为他们确实保持了冷静。所以他走开并发送了CQD，这是国际求救信号。是的，第一次呼叫是在午夜12点15分发出的。CQ是马可尼代码，代表所有电台，D表示紧急呼叫。没错，它在俚语中被称为“快来，危险”（Come Quick Danger）。是的，所以SOS确实存在，SOS是四年前才引入的。
So CQD is the sort of the standard code. It's slightly harder to transmit than SOS, which is why SOS was brought in. And there's this tragic detail, isn't there, that a passenger ship making for Canada, Mount Temple, does receive this, goes to the coordinates given by the Titanic, but they're the wrong coordinates.
所以CQD是标准代码。它比SOS更难传输，这就是为什么引入了SOS。有一个悲剧性的细节，不是吗？一艘前往加拿大的客轮“圣殿山号”（Mount Temple）确实收到了这个信号，前往泰坦尼克号给出的坐标，但那是错误的坐标。
Yeah. And there's another one, actually, the Californian, a freighter. And the guy who's in charge of the wireless on that ship has actually, because it's so late, he's switched off his Marconi apparatus. So that ship comes very close, but it doesn't come close enough.
是的。还有另一艘，实际上是“加利福尼亚号”（Californian），一艘货轮。而那艘船上负责无线电的人，因为时间太晚了，他关掉了他的马可尼设备。所以那艘船离得很近，但没有近到足以……
They don't realise, the Californian does not realise that the Titanic is there and is sinking. And the Carpathia, when does it get through to the Carpathia? The Carpathia, it got the message a little bit later, and the story of the Carpathia when does it get through to the carpathia uh carpathia he got the message a little bit later and the story of the carpathia is an amazing one because the the wireless operator on the carpathia was only 20 years old and he was literally getting into bed and he was just waiting for confirmation on the message that he had sent on the marconi machine when he heard the titanic and had that not happened the survivors would have been in a real mess
他们没有意识到，加利福尼亚号没有意识到泰坦尼克号就在那里并且正在沉没。而卡帕西亚号（Carpathia），它是什么时候收到消息的？卡帕西亚号，它收到消息稍微晚一点，而卡帕西亚号的故事……它是什么时候收到消息的？卡帕西亚号，它收到消息稍微晚一点，而卡帕西亚号的故事是一个了不起的故事，因为卡帕西亚号上的无线电操作员只有20岁，他当时正准备上床睡觉，他只是在等待他发出的马可尼机器上的消息确认，这时他听到了泰坦尼克号的呼叫，如果那没有发生，幸存者们就会陷入真正的困境。
in their lifeboats. Yeah, the Carpathia wouldn't have come. Farmore would have died. So talking of the lifeboats, Tom, we are now at roughly between 12.15 and 12.25, half an hour from the moment when they hit the iceberg. And Captain Smith says, all hands up on deck and get the lifeboats ready.
在他们的救生艇里。是的，卡帕西亚号就不会来。会有更多人死亡。所以说到救生艇，汤姆，我们现在大约在12点15分到12点25分之间，距离他们撞上冰山半小时。史密斯船长说：“全体甲板集合，准备救生艇。”
Now, the issue that he has and that they all have is that they know there are not enough lifeboats. So should we just go through how many lifeboats there are? Yes, sure. So there are two wooden emergency boats, which can each carry 40 occupants. So number one on the starboard, number two on the port. There are 14 wooden lifeboats, which can carry 65 occupants. And they, again, are kind of railed on either side of the ship. And there are four lifeboats, Engelhardt lifeboats. I'm not entirely sure what they are. What are they, Dominic? They have collapsible sides.
现在，他面临的问题，也是他们所有人面临的问题，是他们知道救生艇不够用。所以我们应该过一遍有多少救生艇吗？是的，当然。所以有两艘木制紧急救生艇，每艘可以容纳40人。所以右舷一号，左舷二号。有14艘木制救生艇，每艘可以容纳65人。它们同样安装在船的两侧。还有四艘恩格尔哈特（Engelhardt）救生艇。我不确定那是什么。那是什么，多米尼克？它们有可折叠的侧面。
They're collapsible? Yes. Okay. And they're designated A, B, C, and D? Yeah. How many can they take? 47 occupants? Yes. So there's capacity for a fair few number, but not everyone. No, no, no. Not by any means. So there is deficiency in total, given that the capacity of the Titanic is more than 3,000 people, there is a deficiency of just over 2 000 spaces now the turtanic is not at capacity so basically about a thousand people or so are not going to fit on these and these
它们是可折叠的？是的。好的。它们被指定为A、B、C和D？是的。它们能容纳多少人？47人？是的。所以容量还算不少，但不是每个人都能上。不，不，不。绝不是。所以总数上有缺口，考虑到泰坦尼克号的容量超过3000人，现在缺口有2000多个位置。泰坦尼克号并没有满载，所以基本上大约一千人左右无法容纳在这些
lifeboats but that is still an issue and captain smith and his fellow officers know this they also know the human propensity to panic which they are desperate to avoid. The one thing that runs right through this story is they do not want mobs of people storming the lifeboats, which they are obviously terrified is going to happen. But also they have the issue that they have to actually persuade people to get onto the lifeboats because there is a general reluctance, isn't there? Well, because to remind people, the Titanic is the equivalent of an 11 story building and you have to be lowered in a lifeboat onto the atlantic ocean yeah yeah people very rarely reflect on that you're absolutely right tom would you get into a boat being lowered out of the window of an 11 story building well it's like jumping from a burning
救生艇上，但这仍然是一个问题。史密斯船长和他的军官们知道这一点。他们也知道人类容易恐慌的倾向，他们拼命想要避免这种情况。贯穿这个故事的一件事是，他们不希望人群冲向救生艇，他们显然非常害怕这种情况会发生。但他们也面临一个问题，他们必须真正说服人们进入救生艇，因为有一种普遍的抵触情绪，不是吗？嗯，因为提醒一下，泰坦尼克号相当于一座11层高的建筑，你必须被救生艇降到大西洋上。是的，是的，人们很少反思这一点。你绝对是对的，汤姆。你会进入一艘从11层楼高的窗户降下来的船吗？嗯，这就像从燃烧的
building isn't it i mean you know do you burn to death or do you... Right. You'd be very reluctant to do it. And actually, there had been examples of things going wrong. So there'd been an issue in the English Channel, a P&O liner, Oceana. There'd been a lifeboat that they dropped it in, it had capsized, and it had killed nine people. The men, the crewmen, are worried,
建筑里跳出来，不是吗？我的意思是，你是会被烧死还是……对。你会非常不情愿这样做。事实上，之前也有过出错的例子。英吉利海峡曾发生过一起事故，一艘P&O班轮“大洋号”（Oceana）。有一艘救生艇在放下时倾覆了，导致9人死亡。船员们很担心，
if we fill the lifeboats too full, will the davits, as they are called, and, if we fill the lifeboats too full, will the davits, as they are called, and the tackle from which the lifeboats hang, will they be able to bear the weight? Will they fall in? I mean, in the event they do, don't they? In the event they're fine. And they'd actually been tested beforehand, thoroughly. And so people should have known that they would. But of course, maybe some people haven't read the briefing. It's always the way. So that's an anxiety. First of all, there's the anxiety, can they persuade people to get into the lifeboats? But then there's the other anxiety that if they can persuade people to get into the lifeboats, who is going to be left behind? And the code of behaviour in this period
如果我们把救生艇装得太满，吊艇架（davits）——也就是救生艇悬挂的装置——能承受重量吗？它们会掉下去吗？我的意思是，结果它们确实承受住了，不是吗？结果它们没问题。而且它们之前经过了彻底的测试。所以人们本应该知道它们没问题。但当然，也许有些人没有读过简报。总是这样。所以这是一个焦虑。首先，焦虑的是他们能否说服人们进入救生艇。但随后还有另一个焦虑，如果他们能说服人们进入救生艇，谁会被留下？而这一时期的行为准则
is absolutely clear that it is women and children first. It is. Yes. Which doesn't necessarily mean that men cannot board, but that is open to interpretation. So it's Captain Smith says women and children. Yes. But what does this mean? So different officers interpret this in different ways. So William Murdoch, he understands it to mean put women and children first. Leitola, who is second officer, so just junior to Murdoch, interprets it on his side, he's on the port side, to mean women and children only.
非常明确，那就是妇女和儿童优先。是的。这并不一定意味着男人不能登船，但这可以有不同的解读。所以史密斯船长说“妇女和儿童”。是的。但这意味着什么？所以不同的军官以不同的方式解读这一点。威廉·默多克，他理解为“妇女和儿童优先”。莱托勒（Lightoller），他是二副，比默多克级别低，他在他那一侧（左舷）将其解读为“仅限妇女和儿童”。
Well, you can see why this is such a crucial ambiguity. I mean, this will determine whether hundreds of people live or die on this ship. Because Murdoch thinks, I've got a lifeboat, I've got a crowd of people, I fill it up with what women and children there are, and then the men can fill up the rest of the spaces. Lytola thinks, we wait for all the women and children to be away before we start embarking the men. Because his argument is, if men get a sniff of the chance of a place on a
嗯，你可以看出为什么这是一个如此关键的歧义。我的意思是，这将决定这艘船上数百人的生死。因为默多克想：“我有一艘救生艇，我有一群人，我先装满妇女和儿童，然后男人可以填补剩下的空间。”莱托勒想：“我们等所有妇女和儿童都离开后，再开始让男人登船。”因为他的论点是，如果男人嗅到了一丝进入
lifeboat they'll be piling in they'll all pile in yeah now you can see why both of them think this as it turns out lightoller's insistence he i mean he's one of the great characters the titanic story because as we said in a previous episode he is the guy who is the mark rylance character in dunkirk and he has this kind of heroic role well he's the most senior officer is the guy who is the mark rylance character in dunkirk and he has this kind of heroic role well he's the most senior officer on the ship who survived who survives so he's he's a great sort of name of the titanic story but his rigor probably condemns an awful lot of people unwittingly to death because he is sending away lifeboats with lots of empty places because there are no women and children about. And he won't let husbands get on with their wives.
救生艇的机会，他们就会蜂拥而上，他们都会挤进去。是的。现在你可以看出为什么他们两个都这么想。事实证明，莱托勒的坚持——我的意思是，他是泰坦尼克号故事中的伟大人物之一，因为正如我们在前一集所说，他是《敦刻尔克》中马克·里朗斯（Mark Rylance）那个角色——他扮演着这种英雄角色。嗯，他是船上幸存的最高级别军官。所以他是泰坦尼克号故事中的一个伟大名字，但他的严苛可能在无意中让许多人走向了死亡，因为他送走了许多空着位置的救生艇，因为周围没有妇女和儿童。而且他不让丈夫和妻子一起上船。
Or indeed wearing long trousers for the first time, which we talked about the little boy who got his first pair of long trousers on his birthday the day before. Exactly. A terrible story. So gender is a determinant of whether you're going to survive or not, whether you're a man or whether you're a woman or indeed a child. But another consideration which is often assumed to have applied in the sinking of the Titanic is class. And anyone who has seen the James Cameron film will remember the scene where the gates are locked, the doorways, the kind of grill of the doorways, and they can't get out. But this is not kind of willful class hatred of the poor, is it? No. We talked about this yesterday, that these
或者第一次穿长裤的男孩，我们谈到过那个在生日前一天第一次穿上长裤的小男孩。没错。一个可怕的故事。所以性别是决定你是否能幸存的因素，无论你是男人还是女人，甚至是孩子。但另一个通常被认为在泰坦尼克号沉没中起作用的因素是阶级。任何看过詹姆斯·卡梅隆电影的人都会记得大门被锁住的场景，那些门廊的格栅，他们无法逃脱。但这并不是对穷人的蓄意阶级仇恨，对吧？不。我们昨天谈过这个，这些
lock gates are there because they're required to be locked by US immigration. Exactly. And they are definitely opened by half midnight. Yes. They are slow to open the gates. The gates exist because of US immigration regulations to stop the spread of disease. That is the rationale for it. They do open the gates, I mean, what are we, 45 minutes, 50 minutes after the iceberg has hit? So you can absolutely argue they open them too late no question and the reason they do that is not because they think who cares about the third class people yeah it's because they are literally deluged with with stuff they are in a terrible situation they're trying to do lots of different things the british investigation to this the official investigation because you dug into that didn't you tom i can see you've got the stuff here in the notes yeah that um there are third class passengers who are also often reluctant and this is borne out by a lot of accounts from surviving stewards and officers and things. Third-class passengers were
锁住的门是因为美国移民局要求锁住。没错。而且它们在午夜12点半之前肯定被打开了。是的。他们打开大门的速度很慢。大门的存在是因为美国移民局的规定，为了防止疾病传播。这就是其背后的逻辑。他们确实打开了大门，我的意思是，我们距离撞上冰山已经45分钟、50分钟了？所以你绝对可以说他们打开得太晚了，毫无疑问。而他们这样做的原因并不是因为他们想“谁在乎三等舱的人”，而是因为他们确实被各种事情淹没了，他们处于一种可怕的境地，他们试图做很多不同的事情。英国对此的调查，官方调查——因为你深入研究过那个，汤姆，我可以看到你笔记里有这些资料——是的，有些三等舱乘客也经常表现出抵触情绪，这得到了许多幸存乘务员和军官的证词证实。三等舱乘客
often very reluctant to go up on deck, to get in the lifeboats, to leave their baggage behind, because of course their baggage means so much to them. Well, also lots of them don't speak English. So that's also a consideration. I mean, the confusion and the chaos. So the conclusion for what it's worth and i guess people might might say well they would say that wouldn't they it is no doubt true that the proportion of third class passengers saved falls far short of the proportion of the first and second class but this is accounted for by the greater reluctance of the third class passengers to leave the ship by their unwillingness to part with their baggage by the difficulty in getting them up from their quarters which were at the
经常非常不情愿上甲板，进入救生艇，丢下他们的行李，因为当然，他们的行李对他们来说意义重大。嗯，而且他们很多人不会说英语。所以这也是一个考虑因素。我的意思是，混乱和无序。所以结论是——不管它值多少钱，我想人们可能会说“他们当然会那么说”——毫无疑问，获救的三等舱乘客比例远低于头等舱和二等舱，但这归因于三等舱乘客更不愿离开船只，他们不愿与行李分开，以及将他们从位于船只
stream ends of the ship and by other similar causes and that's borne out tom there's a guy called john hart who's a third class steward and he was in charge of a group of single women couples with children and wives traveling on their own with children and he testified to the inquiry and said they did not believe the ship was hurt in any way and he has been told take the women upstairs he takes a load up some of them say it's very cold and they go back downstairs again some of them say they would rather remain on the ship than be tossed about on the water like a cockle shell yeah and i think that that has the ring of authenticity there are some finnish girls who he's taken up and they get into one of the lifeboats,
末端的舱室带上来的困难，以及其他类似的原因。这一点得到了证实，汤姆。有一个叫约翰·哈特（John Hart）的人，他是三等舱乘务员，他负责一群单身女性、带孩子的夫妇以及独自带着孩子旅行的妻子。他在调查中作证说，他们根本不相信船受到了任何伤害。他被告知“把妇女带到楼上”，他带了一批上去，有些人说“太冷了”，然后又回到了楼下。有些人说他们宁愿留在船上，也不愿像个小贝壳一样在水面上被抛来抛去。是的，我认为这听起来很真实。他带上去的一些芬兰女孩确实进入了一艘救生艇，
but there are actually women who he has put in a lifeboat who get out again and scurry back into the liner where they say it's warmer. I mean, it does seem the case, doesn't it, that there is not deliberate prejudice against third-class passengers as opposed to second and first? No, I don't think so. Certainly on the part of the people allowing people onto the lifeboats. No. That it is very much focused on gender rather than on class. I think what's also true is you might think, well, are there instances where first and second class passengers are saying, particularly first class passengers,
但实际上有些他放进救生艇的妇女又出来了，溜回了客轮，因为她们说那里更暖和。我的意思是，这似乎确实是事实，不是吗？并没有针对三等舱乘客的蓄意偏见，与二等舱和头等舱相比？不，我不这么认为。至少在允许人们进入救生艇的人员方面是这样。不。这更多是关注性别而不是阶级。我认为同样真实的是，你可能会想，是否有头等舱和二等舱乘客——特别是头等舱乘客——在说：
let me through, I've paid more for my tickets and all that. That absolutely does not happen. That would be their code. Exactly. Exactly. Their code. I mean, you could argue their code kills them. Their code of reticence, of noblesse oblige, you know, that actually, if a lifeboat is being sort of sent away, is being lowered, if you're standing there, Tom, I would advise you, do all that you can to get on that lifeboat. Right. Scratching, clawing, doing what? But as we will see, I mean, men who do take advantage of empty seats, they're not pushing
“让我过去，我付了更多的票钱”等等。这绝对没有发生。那会是他们的准则。没错。没错。他们的准则。我的意思是，你可以说他们的准则害死了他们。他们的沉默准则，贵族义务（noblesse oblige），你知道，实际上，如果一艘救生艇正在被送走、正在被放下，如果你站在那里，汤姆，我会建议你，尽你所能进入那艘救生艇。对。抓挠、攀爬，做任何事？但正如我们将看到的，我的意思是，那些利用空位的男人，他们并没有把
women or children out of the way, but they get on because they might as well, because otherwise they're going to drown. I mean, they are not treated well in the aftermath of the Titanic, but we will come to that. No, they're not. No, they're not. I think very harshly. Tom, we should probably take a break, shouldn't we? Should we take a break and we will return and we will get into the granular detail of the appalling, terrifying details of the lifeboats. So we'll be back
妇女或儿童推开，但他们上去了，因为他们本可以，因为否则他们就会淹死。我的意思是，他们在泰坦尼克号之后并没有受到很好的对待，但我们会谈到这一点。不，他们没有。不，他们没有。我认为非常严厉。汤姆，我们可能应该休息一下，对吧？我们休息一下，回来后我们将深入探讨救生艇那些令人震惊、恐怖的细节。所以我们马上回来。
in a second. I'm Marina Hyde. And I'm Richard Osman. And together we host The Rest Is Entertainment. It's your weekly fix of entertainment news, reviews, splash of showbiz gossip. And on our Q&A, we pull back the curtain on entertainment and we tell you how it all works. We have just launched our Members Club. If you want ad-free listening, bonus episodes and early access to live tickets, head to therestisentertainment.com. That's therestisentertainment.com. Hello, welcome back to The Rest Is History. So Titanic has hit the
我是玛丽娜·海德（Marina Hyde）。我是理查德·奥斯曼（Richard Osman）。我们共同主持《娱乐的余味》（The Rest Is Entertainment）。这是您每周的娱乐新闻、评论和一点点演艺圈八卦的固定节目。在我们的问答环节中，我们揭开了娱乐界的幕布，告诉您这一切是如何运作的。我们刚刚推出了我们的会员俱乐部。如果您想要无广告收听、额外剧集和抢先获得现场演出门票，请前往 therestisentertainment.com。网址是 therestisentertainment.com。你好，欢迎回到《历史的余味》。所以泰坦尼克号撞上了
iceberg. It is starting to sink and the lifeboats are being prepared. Dominic, let's go through and look at the process by which some people get into these boats and some people don't. Yes. So the first lifeboat to be launched is on the starboard side. So this is lifeboat number seven, and this is supervised by Mr. Murdoch. So you will remember from the first half of this episode that Murdoch's attitude is women and children first, and then we'll fill up with men if they are there so one of the issues of course they have is they're in a hurry they're constantly wanting to get a lifeboat away to make room so they can load another lifeboat yeah but also the lifeboat has to get away because when the ship sinks i mean that will create quite a wash exactly so the longer they
冰山。它开始下沉，救生艇也准备好了。多米尼克，我们来梳理一下人们登上这些救生艇的过程，看看为什么有些人能上去，而有些人不能。是的。第一艘下水的救生艇在右舷。这是7号救生艇，由默多克先生负责。大家还记得这集前半部分提到的，默多克的态度是妇女和儿童优先，如果有空位再让男人上。当然，他们面临的问题之一是时间紧迫，他们必须不断地把救生艇放下去，以便腾出空间装载下一艘。是的，而且救生艇必须尽快离开，因为当船沉没时，会产生巨大的漩涡。没错，所以他们离开的时间越早，生存的几率就越大。
have to get away the more likely they will be to survive. And as a result of all this, an enormous proportion of these lifeboats are leaving with lots of extra capacity, not filled. And this is the case with this very first one. It sets the tone. There are 26 people on the lifeboat. Three of them are crewmen. 23 of them are first-class passengers. Of course, the first-class passengers. Of course, the first-class passengers are very close to the decks. So it makes sense that the first-class passengers are the first ones to be got away. But there are 39 spaces. So in other words, it's less than half full. Because at this point, people are still saying, well, what's the point? Can't we just wait? It'll be all right. I mean, there are three guys who were French guys who've been playing bridge downstairs. Monsieur Chevret, Maréchal and Aumont.
因此，这些救生艇中有很大一部分离开时都留有大量空位，并没有装满。第一艘救生艇就是这种情况。它定下了基调。救生艇上有26人。其中3人是船员，23人是头等舱乘客。当然，头等舱乘客离甲板最近。所以头等舱乘客先被送走是有道理的。但救生艇有39个座位。换句话说，它连一半都没坐满。因为在那个时候，人们还在说，有什么意义呢？我们不能再等等吗？会没事的。有三个法国人在楼下打桥牌。谢夫雷先生、马雷夏尔先生和奥蒙先生。
They get on Lifeboat 7 when there are spaces and there's a call generally, men. They get on and they remember afterwards people saying, what's the point? Yeah. Why bother? You know, it'll be fine. Yeah. So Lifeboat 7 was between 1230 and 1245. So about an hour after hitting the iceberg.
当救生艇还有空位且有人呼喊男人上船时，他们就上去了。事后他们回忆起人们说的话：“有什么意义呢？何必呢？你知道，会没事的。”所以7号救生艇是在12点30分到12点45分之间离开的，也就是撞上冰山大约一小时后。
Next one, 10 minutes later, is lifeboat five. That leaves about two-thirds full, so there are 36 passengers on this one. Still, people are very reluctant. Then we have the first port lifeboats on the other side. So this is where Lightoller is, and he is not letting any men on at all. Yeah, and this one is extraordinary. There are 37 empty places and 28 occupants of this lifeboat because he will not let men on.
下一艘是10分钟后的5号救生艇。它离开时大约坐了三分之二满，上面有36名乘客。人们仍然非常不情愿。然后是左舷的第一批救生艇。这是莱托勒负责的地方，他根本不让任何男人上船。是的，这一艘的情况非常特殊。这艘救生艇有37个空位，却只有28名乘客，因为他不让男人上船。
And there's really one of a multitude of very moving stories on this lifeboat. So there was a woman called Eloise Smith, a sort of society lady from the United States. She's a suffragist. She's a member of the Republican Party. She is there with her husband, Lucien. And remember, we said there were 37 empty places on this lifeboat. And she is standing there with her husband,
在这艘救生艇上，发生了一个非常感人的故事。有一位名叫埃洛伊丝·史密斯的女士，她是来自美国的社交名媛。她是妇女参政论者，也是共和党成员。她和丈夫卢西安在一起。记住，我们说过这艘救生艇有37个空位。她和丈夫站在那里，
and she asks Captain Smith personally, who is standing there, she says, can my husband get into one of these empty spaces? And he ignores her, and he shouts through his megaphone, women and children first. And her husband, he does that classic thing, Tom. He does the right thing. He says, nevermind captain about that. I'll see she gets in the boat. And then he says to his wife, I never expected to ask you to obey me, but this is one time you must. It's only a matter of form to have women and children first the boat is thoroughly equipped and everyone on her will be saved this is her husband saying this yeah and she says you're telling me the truth yes he kisses her his last thing he says is keep your hands in your pockets because it's going to be very cold then she's
她亲自问站在那里的史密斯船长，她说，我丈夫能进这些空位中的一个吗？船长无视了她，通过扩音器大喊：妇女和儿童优先。她的丈夫，他做了那个经典的举动，汤姆。他做了正确的事。他说，别管那个了，船长。我会看着她上船的。然后他对妻子说，我从没想过要让你服从我，但这次你必须听我的。妇女和儿童优先只是个形式，救生艇装备齐全，船上的每个人都会获救。这是她丈夫说的。她问，你是在跟我说实话吗？是的。他吻了她，他说的最后一句话是：把手放在口袋里，因为会非常冷。然后她被
lowered and that's the last time she ever sees him. And of course, for the rest of her life, it nags at her. And if she'd been on the other side with Murdoch, he'd have been in with her. He would have allowed him to go. Yeah. And that she was lowered with 37 spaces next to her and her husband was not allowed to take one of them up. I mean, a terrible, terrible story. So one o'clock in the morning and they start to fire distress signals yeah kind of
放下了救生艇，那是她最后一次见到他。当然，在她的余生中，这件事一直折磨着她。如果她当时在默多克负责的那一侧，他就能和她一起上船了。他会允许他上去的。是的。她被放下时旁边有37个空位，而她的丈夫却不被允许占用其中任何一个。真是个极其悲惨的故事。凌晨一点，他们开始发射遇险信号，是的，
flames going up in the air and everyone finds this very unsettling and alarming i mean understandably yeah as you would as you would i mean not just because it's a signal of um the ship is in real distress but also because they're very loud and yeah you know unsettling the whole experience is now becoming quite frightening for people i think yes and Yes. And also at one o'clock, lifeboat one leaves. And this contains a very controversial escapee, namely Sir Cosmo Duff Gordon, who is the stiff, uptight fencer and his wife, the lingerie designer. Yeah. But they are two of the five passengers and seven crewmen who got on this lifeboat. So another lifeboat that leaves not even remotely close to being half full.
火焰升向空中，每个人都觉得这非常令人不安和惊恐。当然，确实如此。不仅仅是因为这是船只陷入真正困境的信号，还因为它们声音很大，整个经历现在对人们来说变得相当可怕。是的，而且在一点钟，1号救生艇离开了。上面有一个非常有争议的逃生者，即科斯莫·达夫·戈登爵士，那个死板、拘谨的击剑手，以及他的妻子，那位内衣设计师。是的。但他们是登上这艘救生艇的5名乘客和7名船员中的两人。所以这又是另一艘离开时连一半都没坐满的救生艇。
So 28 spaces on this lifeboat. There's a Cosmo. There's his wife. There's her secretary, Laura Francatelli. And there's a Manhattan wholesaler called Abraham Salomon and a guy called henry stengel and they say to murdoch as he's loading lady duff gordon wants her husband to come in she says can he come and murdoch says yeah get in yeah you know obviously it strikes him as mad not to allow men to take up the empty spaces but also he's really desperate to get that lifeboat away because he knows that
这艘救生艇有28个座位。有科斯莫，有他的妻子，有她的秘书劳拉·弗兰卡泰利，还有一个叫亚伯拉罕·所罗门的曼哈顿批发商，以及一个叫亨利·斯滕格尔的人。当默多克装载救生艇时，他们对他说，达夫·戈登夫人想让她丈夫上来，她问他能上来吗？默多克说，行，上来吧。显然，他不让男人占用空位在他看来很疯狂，而且他非常急于让救生艇离开，因为他知道
there are bigger lifeboats to come. So he needs the hooks to get the bigger lifeboats in. So he says, just get it away, get it away. And of course, when this story gets out, it's incredibly controversial afterwards that Sir Cosmo Duff Gordon and Lady Dve Gordon left on basically an empty lifeboat. Yeah, but also what turbocharges it is that Sir Cosmo then tips the sailors on board, doesn't he? The members of the crew. He does. And so this is then remembered and interpreted as being a bribe. Especially in America.
还有更大的救生艇要来。所以他需要挂钩来放下更大的救生艇。所以他说，快让它走，快让它走。当然，当这个故事传开后，科斯莫·达夫·戈登爵士和达夫·戈登夫人坐着一艘几乎空着的救生艇离开，这在事后引起了极大的争议。是的，而且更火上浇油的是，科斯莫爵士后来还给了船上的水手小费，不是吗？那些船员。是的。所以这被记住并被解读为贿赂。特别是在美国。
But you'd think Americans would love this, I mean, with their culture of tipping, Tom. I think they were good tippers then. I think there's been a cultural sea change since the 1910s. So he is someone who will be definitely condemned for having gone. Yeah. I think unfairly. I think totally unfairly. So Theo, our producer, has written in the chat,
但你以为美国人会喜欢这个，毕竟他们有给小费的文化，汤姆。我想他们那时给小费很大方。自1910年代以来，文化已经发生了翻天覆地的变化。所以他肯定会因为离开而受到谴责。是的。我认为是不公平的。我认为完全不公平。所以我们的制片人西奥在聊天中写道，
he says, surely letting men on is better than half full boats. Yes. I mean, Theo, I think everybody would agree with that. Well, unless you're Officer Lightoller. But Lightoller's not mad. I mean, Lightoller's argument is, once you say there are places for men, there is a danger that actually women and children will just be pushed aside and men will... You don't think that would have happened, Tom?
他说，让男人上船肯定比救生艇半空着要好。是的。西奥，我想每个人都会同意这一点。嗯，除非你是莱托勒副官。但莱托勒并不疯狂。莱托勒的论点是，一旦你说有男人的位置，就有可能导致妇女和儿童被推到一边，而男人会……你不认为会发生那种事吗，汤姆？
No, because it didn't on the other side. No, it didn't. I suppose you're right. Yeah. Yeah, but you can understand why he thinks yeah of course i can of course i can but it does seem very very harsh crazily harsh so i mean the eloise smith story there are many such stories of women who are standing with their husbands and their husband is not allowed to take up the place next to them
不，因为在另一边并没有发生。不，确实没有。我想你是对的。是的，但你可以理解他为什么会那么想。当然可以，当然可以，但这看起来确实非常非常严厉，极其严厉。所以，埃洛伊丝·史密斯的故事，有许多这样的故事，妇女们和丈夫站在一起，而丈夫却不被允许占用旁边的位置。
so we were just on starboard weren't we lifeboat Lifeboat one. So back on port side, light huller side, about 110. There really is a growing sense of panic now, I think. Nobody's deluded anymore about what is happening. And so men are starting to think through the implications of the fact that they're not being allowed on. And there is a certain swelling of anxiety, perhaps one might say. I think absolutely there is. And Captain Smith is having none of it. Behave yourselves like men.
我们刚才在右舷，对吧，1号救生艇。回到左舷，莱托勒那一侧，大约1点10分。我想现在恐慌感真的在增长。没有人再对正在发生的事情抱有幻想了。所以男人们开始思考他们不被允许上船这一事实的含义。可以说，焦虑感在不断膨胀。我想绝对是这样。史密斯船长对此不予理会。像个男人一样表现。
Look at all of those women. See how splendid they are. Can't you behave like men? I love Captain Smith. Well, he obviously, I mean, it works, doesn't it? Because he basically, every time he, in his sort of sea dog style, he shouts this, the men pipe down.
看看那些妇女。看看她们是多么出色。你们就不能像个男人一样吗？我喜欢史密斯船长。嗯，他显然，我是说，这很管用，不是吗？因为他基本上每次用他那种老海员的风格大喊时，男人们就安静下来了。
I would behave like Cal on the film. I would grab a baby. Would you? Yeah, I would. Yes, of course. Billy Zane's character. Yes. And there is a kind of abiding urban myth,
我会像电影里的卡尔那样做。我会抓住一个婴儿。你会吗？是的，我会。当然。比利·赞恩饰演的角色。是的。而且有一个根深蒂固的都市传说，
which has never been proved, that there is a man who disguises himself as a woman to get on board. Yes, that's right. That's right. So now Lifeboat 8 goes away from the port side. Then Lightoller loads another lifeboat, lifeboat 10. There are quite a lot of second-class women and children in this lifeboat. A good example, there's a family called the Wests from Cornwall. They're going to Florida. Arthur West has his, I mean, this is a very moving story. He's got his two
从未被证实，说有一个男人伪装成女人才得以登船。是的，没错。没错。现在8号救生艇从左舷离开了。然后莱托勒装载了另一艘，10号救生艇。这艘救生艇上有相当多的二等舱妇女和儿童。一个很好的例子，有一个来自康沃尔的韦斯特家庭。他们要去佛罗里达。亚瑟·韦斯特有他的，这是一个非常感人的故事。他有两个
daughters, little girls who are sleepy. He puts them in their life jackets. He carries them to the boat deck. His wife, Ada, is pregnant. He lowers Ada and the two little girls into the lifeboat. He lowers a thermos flask of hot milk for his youngest daughter, who's 11 months old, by rope to his wife in the lifeboat. And that is the last time she ever sees him because, of course, he's not allowed in. And, Dominic, there's a very similar story about Joseph Laroche, who people listen to our episode on the second class passengers will remember. He is the only black man on the Titanic and he has his wife and two daughters.
女儿，小女孩们很困。他给她们穿上救生衣。他把她们抱到船甲板上。他的妻子艾达怀孕了。他把艾达和两个小女孩放进救生艇。他用绳子把一个装有热牛奶的保温瓶放下去，给11个月大的小女儿。那是她最后一次见到他，因为当然，他不被允许上船。多米尼克，关于约瑟夫·拉罗什也有一个非常相似的故事，听过我们关于二等舱乘客那一集的人会记得。他是泰坦尼克号上唯一的黑人，他有妻子和两个女儿。
And there is a similar scene. He gets them into the lifeboat. They're lowered and he is never seen again either. Yeah, they're actually awful stories aren't they and then dominic there's a very moving story very famous story of the strausses so isidor strauss was one of the three plutocrats on board who in the conspiracy theory is deliberately killed by jp morgan yeah which is clearly not true and he is with his wife ida and uh he's told that he can board lifeboat three yeah nobody would object to an old gentleman like you getting in exactly and he says i will not go
也有类似的场景。他让她们上了救生艇。她们被放下去，他就再也没出现过。是的，这些故事真的很可怕，不是吗？然后多米尼克，有一个非常感人、非常著名的斯特劳斯夫妇的故事。伊西多·斯特劳斯是船上的三位大亨之一，在阴谋论中，他被摩根故意杀害，这显然不是真的。他和妻子艾达在一起，有人告诉他可以登上3号救生艇，没人会反对像您这样的老绅士上去。他却说，我不会
before the other men he refuses to accept that and then his wife refuses to go i will not be separated from my husband as we have lived so we will die together. And so then they basically, they kind of wrap up and sit on deck chairs together and wait for their doom. They appear in the film where they are shown kind of hugging each other on a bed, but in reality, they perished on board. But I mean, either way, the story is so moving, isn't it?
在其他男人之前离开。他拒绝接受这一点，然后他的妻子拒绝离开。我不会和我的丈夫分开。我们怎么生活，就怎么一起死去。于是他们基本上收拾了一下，坐在甲板椅上等待命运。他们在电影中出现，被展示为在床上互相拥抱，但实际上，他们是在船上遇难的。但无论如何，这个故事太感人了，不是吗？
Yeah, because she was heard saying to him later on, we've been living together for many years where you go i go that she wouldn't leave him that she knew it meant certain death and the story of their self-sacrifice immediately became a part of titanic mythology so i think it mattered that they were jewish because for the jewish community in new york this was seen as tremendous heroism and their rab rabbi in New York said of Strauss, he was a loyal son of his people, a loyal American. Isidore Strauss was a great Jew. And now when we are asked, can a Jew die bravely? There is an answer written in the annals of time.
是的，因为后来有人听到她对他说，我们在一起生活了很多年，你去哪里我就去哪里。她不会离开他，她知道这意味着必死无疑。他们自我牺牲的故事立即成为了泰坦尼克号神话的一部分。我认为他们是犹太人这一点很重要，因为对于纽约的犹太社区来说，这被视为巨大的英雄主义。他们在纽约的拉比谈到斯特劳斯时说，他是他人民的忠诚儿子，一个忠诚的美国人。伊西多·斯特劳斯是一位伟大的犹太人。现在当我们被问到，犹太人能勇敢地死去吗？答案已经写在时间的编年史中了。
He's not the only Jew to die bravely though. So Ben Guggenheim, we talked about him, didn't we? Suave, son of the Leadville, Colorado, silver mine dynasty. So he does what I think I would actually do in this situation, which is to go and don dinner dress. Do you know what? His final lines were heard by a steward. I mean, I'm sure I won't say this on my deathbed, but I'd like to believe that I would. I am willing to remain and play the man's
但他并不是唯一勇敢死去的犹太人。本·古根海姆，我们谈过他，对吧？风度翩翩，来自科罗拉多州利德维尔银矿王朝的儿子。所以他做了我认为我在那种情况下真的会做的事，那就是去穿上晚礼服。你知道吗？他的遗言被一名乘务员听到了。我是说，我肯定不会在临终时说出这样的话，但我希望我相信我会。我愿意留下来，像个男人一样
game if there are not enough boats for more than the women and children i won't die here like a beast tell my wife i played the game out straight into the end no woman shall be left aboard this ship because ben guggenheim was a coward yeah you see so i can't decide whether i would do that right and dress up in black tie and be in sushi or dress as a woman or whether i would do that and dress up in black tie and be in sushi on. Or dress as a woman. Or whether I would dress as a woman, grow a baby, and jump screaming and howling and sobbing into the lifeboat. I can't decide.
玩这场游戏。如果救生艇不够多，无法容纳妇女和儿童，我就不会像野兽一样死在这里。告诉我的妻子，我一直坚持到了最后。没有女人会被留在船上。因为本·古根海姆是个懦夫。是的，你看，所以我无法决定我是会那样做，穿上黑领结去赴死，还是伪装成女人，或者我会那样做，穿上黑领结去赴死。或者伪装成女人。或者我会伪装成女人，抱着一个婴儿，尖叫着、嚎哭着跳进救生艇。我无法决定。
Surely the ideal would be to do both. Be heard loudly saying, but then disguise yourself in a shawl as a sort of Croat peasant. Yes. And then you'd have to live a false life. Well, you'd have to live like a Croat peasant for the rest of your life. You would. Which would be very poor if you were originally a billionaire.
理想的情况肯定是两者兼顾。大声说出那番话，然后伪装成一个克罗地亚农民。是的。那你得过一种虚假的生活。嗯，你得在余生中像个克罗地亚农民一样生活。你会的。如果你原本是个亿万富翁，那会很惨。
Ben Guggenheim. Yeah. But it'd be better than being dead, I think it's fair to say. And also, Tom, imagine the satisfaction you'd get in later life, years later. Reading your obituaries. Yeah. Or watching Hollywood films about the titanic seeing your own amazing lines but knowing you'd fooled the world so that's very heroic and i think even more
本·古根海姆。是的。但我认为公平地说，这总比死了好。而且，汤姆，想象一下你以后，多年后会得到的满足感。读着你的讣告。或者看着关于泰坦尼克号的好莱坞电影，看到你自己那些惊人的台词，但知道你骗过了全世界。所以这非常英勇，而且我认为更
famously heroic are the musicians oh yeah because the band really does play on doesn't it it does it absolutely does this is probably the most famous story of all certainly the most famous band story i think it's fair to say. Don't you think? I mean, I suppose the two things that everyone knows about Sinking the Titanic is women and children first and the band plays on. Yeah. And I was so delighted to learn that they really did. So the band leader was a guy called Wallace Hartley, who was from Colne in Lancashire.
著名的英勇事迹是那些音乐家。哦，是的，因为乐队确实一直在演奏，不是吗？确实如此。这可能是所有故事中最著名的，当然也是最著名的乐队故事，我认为可以这么说。你不觉得吗？我是说，我想每个人都知道关于泰坦尼克号沉没的两件事：妇女和儿童优先，以及乐队一直在演奏。是的。我很高兴得知他们确实这么做了。乐队领队是一个叫华莱士·哈特利的人，来自兰开夏郡的科尔恩。
And he and his bandmates, they just started playing to keep the passengers calm while the lifeboats were being loaded. Lots of survivors said they played right up until the last minute. In the film, am I right in saying he says, as I recall, the band leader says to his other musicians, oh, you can all go now. Yeah, and they do head off. He stays, and they're shamed, and then come back.
他和他的乐队成员开始演奏，以在装载救生艇时保持乘客冷静。许多幸存者说他们一直演奏到最后一刻。在电影中，我记得没错的话，乐队领队对他的其他音乐家说，哦，你们现在都可以走了。是的，他们确实离开了。他留下了，他们感到羞愧，然后又回来了。
And they play with him. Yeah, it's do head off. He stays and they're shamed and then come back. And they play with him. Yeah, it's very, very moving. And actually, amazingly, it is said that his body was found in evening dress in the ocean with his music case strapped to it. Yeah. And so he gets an absolute hero's funeral, doesn't he, back in England? In Lancashire, yeah. Colne's hero, Britain's hero, the world's hero. Thousands of people came to his funeral, this guy Wallace Hartley. So it's a weird thing with the Titanic story, isn't it? Because one of the things that's moving is obviously the tragedy, the sacrifice, and the sort episode, lots of people like Churchill saw it as an absolutely inspirational, heroic story that actually in the darkest, darkest situation possible, people discovered these reserves of courage and stoicism that they would never have previously imagined they had.
他们和他一起演奏。是的，非常非常感人。而且令人惊奇的是，据说他的尸体被发现时穿着晚礼服，漂浮在海洋中，音乐盒还绑在身上。是的。所以他回英国后举行了绝对英雄般的葬礼，不是吗？在兰开夏郡，是的。科尔恩的英雄，英国的英雄，世界的英雄。成千上万的人参加了他的葬礼，这个叫华莱士·哈特利的人。所以泰坦尼克号的故事很奇怪，不是吗？因为感人的事情之一显然是悲剧、牺牲，以及那个插曲。很多人像丘吉尔一样，认为这是一个绝对鼓舞人心的英雄故事，实际上在最黑暗、最黑暗的情况下，人们发现了他们以前从未想象过的勇气和坚忍。
Yeah. Although by now it's 1.30 and panic is starting to spread. Oh, yes. Yeah. Because people are now beginning to try to force their way onto lifeboat so lifeboat 14 there's a story a widow from st i's called agnes davis she knows the space this is on light on her side she says please come my son who is 19 get onto the boat with me and the officers say we will shoot him if he tries to get onto the lifeboat. Same lifeboat.
是的。虽然现在已经是1点30分，恐慌开始蔓延。哦，是的。是的，因为人们现在开始试图强行登上救生艇。所以14号救生艇，有一个故事，一个来自圣艾夫斯的寡妇叫艾格尼丝·戴维斯，她知道有空间，这是在莱托勒那一侧，她说，请让我的儿子，他19岁，和我一起上船。军官们说，如果他试图登上救生艇，我们就开枪打死他。同一艘救生艇。
Some people may remember from the last episode, I think it was, or the last couple of episodes, we had a story of a family called the Colliers. So these are the ones from Hampshire, the bell ringer. Yeah, from Hampshire. And they'd rung the bells of the church just before they left. Charlotte Collier won't leave her husband and she won't get into the first lifeboat. And then eventually she's forced because a sailor grabs her daughter, Marjorie,
有些人可能还记得上一集，或者前几集，我们讲过一个叫科利尔家庭的故事。他们是来自汉普郡的，敲钟人。是的，来自汉普郡。他们在离开前刚刚敲响了教堂的钟。夏洛特·科利尔不愿离开丈夫，她不愿登上第一艘救生艇。然后最终她被迫了，因为一个水手抓住了她的女儿玛乔里，
and throws her into a lifeboat. She has to get in. She's in her light gown. Her husband is shouting to her, go Lottie, for God's's sake be brave and go i'll get a seat in another boat she's basically bundled into the lifeboat by sailors and she looks back doesn't she and sees her husband's back walking away walking away and that's the last she ever sees of him and basically her life is she is traumatized for the rest of her life yeah by this
把她扔进了救生艇。她不得不上去。她穿着睡袍。她的丈夫对她大喊，走吧，洛蒂，看在上帝的份上，勇敢点，走吧，我会坐另一艘船的。她基本上被水手们塞进了救生艇，她回头看，不是吗？看到她丈夫的背影走开了，走开了，那是她最后一次见到他。基本上她的余生，她余生都受到了创伤。是的，因为这个。
i let myself be saved because i believed that he too would escape, but I sometimes envy those whom no earthly power could tear from their husband's arms. 16-year-old Liverpudlian Cooper, or Cooper's apprentice, Andrew Gaskell, who has been taken by a smooth, handsome bachelor to Canada. And he somehow sort of sneaks into the lifeboat, doesn't he? He's hoping to be invited in. He's never let on. Then he kind of just jumps in and the women cover him up. Then he is spotted by an officer, the fifth officer, Harold Lowe, who draws his revolver and says, you've got 10 seconds to get back on the ship or I'll blow your brains out.
我让自己获救是因为我相信他也能逃脱，但我有时羡慕那些没有任何世俗力量能将她们从丈夫怀抱中撕开的人。16岁的利物浦人库珀，或者库珀的学徒安德鲁·加斯克尔，他被一个风度翩翩的单身汉带到了加拿大。他不知怎么地溜进了救生艇，不是吗？他希望能被邀请进去。他从未被允许。然后他只是跳了进去，女人们把他盖住。然后他被一名军官，第五军官哈罗德·洛发现了，他拔出左轮手枪说，你有10秒钟时间回到船上，否则我就打爆你的头。
And the boy is begging and sobbing. And then the officer says, that hasn't worked. And then he changes his tone and he says, for God's sake, be a man. We've got women and children to save. We must stop at the decks lower down and take on women and children, which actually wasn't true. They weren't going to stop at the decks lower down.
那个男孩在乞求和啜泣。然后军官说，那没用。然后他改变了语气说，看在上帝的份上，像个男人。我们有妇女和儿童要救。我们必须在下面的甲板停下来，接上妇女和儿童，这其实不是真的。他们并没有打算在下面的甲板停下来。
But the boy gets out kind of sobbing. The women are all sobbing. And that must have been the end of him, Tom. That must have condemned him to death. So the fact that officers have guns and are brandishing them by this point, we should talk about, again, one of the most notorious incidents, him to death. So the fact that officers have guns and are brandishing them by this point, we should talk about, again, one of the most notorious incidents, which is again shown in
但男孩还是下去了，啜泣着。女人们都在啜泣。那一定是他的末日了，汤姆。那一定注定了他会死。所以军官们在这一点上拿着枪并挥舞着，我们应该谈谈，再次提到，最臭名昭著的事件之一，
the film. And this is the claim that William Murdoch, the man who effectively had been responsible for the collision with the iceberg, the ripping open of the hull, that he shoots a man and then shoots himself. And everyone who's seen the film will remember that. And this is drawing on authentic rumors from the time. So these rumors were denied by Lytola. So Murdoch doesn't survive, but Lytola does. And he says that he saw Murdoch busy working to free lifeboats when he was swept into the sea by a great wave crashing up, so that that's how he dies. And after the film came out, Murdoch's nephew sees it and is so offended on Murdoch's behalf that he complains. And in fact, film executives fly to Murdoch's
这在电影中也有所表现。这就是威廉·默多克，那个实际上对撞上冰山、撕裂船体负有责任的人，他开枪打死了一个人，然后自杀了。看过电影的人都会记得这一点。这是基于当时真实的传闻。所以这些传闻被莱托勒否认了。默多克没有幸存，但莱托勒幸存了。他说他看到默多克忙于解开救生艇，这时一个巨大的海浪冲上来，把他卷入海中，这就是他死亡的方式。电影上映后，默多克的侄子看到了，并为默多克感到非常冒犯，他提出了投诉。事实上，电影高管们飞往默多克的
hometown to apologise. And James Cameron says that the depiction of Murdoch in the film wasn't meant to be negative. He says, I'm not sure you'd find that same sense of responsibility and total devotion to duty today. This guy had half of his lifeboats launched before his counterpart on the port side had even launched one. That says something about his character and heroism. So there is, I think, a sense that this didn't happen, but there is a counter view that Lightoller might have said what he said because he didn't want to upset Murdoch's widow. So he may deliberately have told a white lie. And adding to the possibility that Murdoch did commit suicide is the fact that he would have known that his career was over and he may well have felt such a burden of guilt what he did. Yeah, we just don't know though. So it's unproven. But I mean, it is a kind of one of those mysteries that shadows our sense of the story, kind of glimpse into the horror of the moment, I think. 20th Century Fox actually gave a donation. Murdoch's old school had a fund, a memorial fund, which I assume is still running. And 20th Century Fox actually gave them a donation
家乡道歉。詹姆斯·卡梅隆说，电影中对默多克的描绘并不是要表现负面。他说，我不确定你今天还能找到那种同样的责任感和对职责的绝对奉献。这家伙在左舷的同行甚至还没放下第一艘救生艇之前，就已经放下了一半的救生艇。这说明了他的性格和英雄主义。所以我认为有一种感觉，这件事并没有发生，但有一种反面观点认为，莱托勒可能说了他所说的话，因为他不想让默多克的遗孀难过。所以他可能故意撒了一个善意的谎言。默多克可能自杀的可能性还增加了，因为他会知道他的职业生涯结束了，他很可能对自己所做的事情感到沉重的内疚。是的，我们只是不知道。所以这没有被证实。但我的意思是，这是一种笼罩在我们对这个故事的理解中的谜团，我认为这是一种对那一刻恐怖的窥视。20世纪福克斯实际上捐了一笔款。默多克的母校有一个基金，一个纪念基金，我想现在还在运行。20世纪福克斯实际上给了他们一笔捐款
to say sorry. Well, good on them. They didn't publicly apologise. The interesting thing with all those stories, so there are lots of stories and rumours about what happened to the captain, Captain Smith. Of course, the only honest answer is nobody could possibly know. And at that point in the night, it's so chaotic anyway, and the panic has now spread so widely. So a steward reports seeing Smith walk to the bridge.
来表示歉意。嗯，他们做得好。他们没有公开道歉。所有这些故事中有趣的事情是，关于史密斯船长发生了什么，有很多故事和传闻。当然，唯一诚实的回答是没人可能知道。在那个时候的夜晚，无论如何都很混乱，恐慌现在已经蔓延得如此广泛。所以一名乘务员报告说看到史密斯走向舰桥。
Yeah. And it is generally thought, isn't it, that he dies on the bridge? Yeah. So that, I think, is, I mean, it's not just possible, it's plausible. So that's what's shown happening on the film. Yes, it is, isn't it? He's holding the wheel or something, I can't remember. But there are greater implausibilities.
是的。人们普遍认为，不是吗，他死在舰桥上了？是的。所以，我想，我是说，这不仅是可能的，而且是合理的。所以这就是电影中发生的事情。是的，是吗？他握着舵轮还是什么的，我不记得了。但还有更大的不可信之处。
So there's his last words, be British, boys, be British, which I think appears on his memorial. Oh, he definitely said that, Tom. He undoubtedly said that. But I think that's invented later. And there are kind of various JFK type theories that he was spotted. Right. Few years later, cocktails in New York, that kind of thing. But I think that all of these reflect the fact that it is complete chaos and nobody really knows what is going on. And this, I think, is the context for the other notorious event that happens at around this point, which is that Bruce Ismay is one of
所以有他的遗言，“做个英国人，小伙子们，做个英国人”，我想这出现在他的纪念碑上。哦，他肯定说了那句话，汤姆。他无疑说了那句话。但我认为那是后来编造的。还有各种肯尼迪式的理论，说他被看到了。对。几年后，在纽约喝鸡尾酒，诸如此类的事情。但我认为所有这些都反映了一个事实，即当时完全是一片混乱，没人真正知道发生了什么。我认为这就是此时发生的另一件臭名昭著事件的背景，那就是布鲁斯·伊斯梅是
the men who gets into a boat. So Bruce Ismay, to remind people, he is Mr. White Star, isn't he? Yeah. He had inherited White Star effectively from his father, who was this sort of rough-edged shipbuilding tycoon, Bruce Ismay. His father had tried to make him into a gentleman. He is the personification of White Star, of the transatlantic race of the trade to the world. And he's despised by americans as someone who's inherited his position from his father and he's despised by the british as a kind of upstart man in trade so he is he's a man without allies on either side of the atlantic really yeah and that means that what happens next is is presented in the darkest shade possible
登上救生艇的男人之一。所以布鲁斯·伊斯梅，提醒大家，他是白星航运的先生，不是吗？是的。他实际上是从他父亲那里继承了白星航运，他父亲是那种粗犷的造船大亨，布鲁斯·伊斯梅。他父亲曾试图把他培养成绅士。他是白星航运、跨大西洋贸易、世界贸易的化身。他被美国人鄙视，认为他继承了父亲的职位，他被英国人鄙视，认为他是一个贸易界的暴发户。所以他是一个在大西洋两岸都没有盟友的人，真的。是的，这意味着接下来发生的事情被呈现得尽可能黑暗。
because we're now it's 140 lifeboat40, Lifeboat Sea is being loaded. Various people who we've met before are getting on it. So Emily Goldsmith and her young son, Frankie, this is the people who are taking the boy, Alfred Rush, who's just been given his long trousers. So the husband doesn't get in, you know, kisses his son on the forehead. So long, Frankie, I'll see you later. Alfred Rush in his long trousers does not get in because he's proud to be a man. I'm staying here. Yeah. A crewman is trying to pull him on.
因为现在是1点40分，40号救生艇，C号救生艇正在装载。我们之前见过的一些人正在上去。所以艾米丽·戈德史密斯和她的小儿子弗兰基，这就是带着那个男孩阿尔弗雷德·拉什的人，他刚刚穿上长裤。所以丈夫没有上去，你知道，亲吻了他儿子的额头。再见，弗兰基，回头见。穿着长裤的阿尔弗雷德·拉什没有上去，因为他为自己是个男人而自豪。我留在这里。是的。一名船员试图把他拉上去。
He looks, we said before, he looks young and he says, I am staying with the men. And he's there in his trousers and he's so proud of himself. Yeah. And of course, he's condemning himself to death. And so this is when Ismay gets in. So Ismay has been behaving well. He's been helping
他看起来，我们之前说过，他看起来很年轻，他说，我和男人们在一起。他穿着长裤站在那里，他为自己感到非常自豪。是的。当然，他是在判自己死刑。所以这就是伊斯梅上去的时候。所以伊斯梅表现得很好。他一直在帮助
get people onto the lifeboats. He is urged to get on the lifeboat by one of the sailors. Gets in. But there are various accounts that he jumps in earlier, whatever. But I think the consensus
人们登上救生艇。他被其中一名水手敦促登上救生艇。上去了。但有各种说法说他跳得更早，等等。但我认为共识
would be that probably it's as with the Duff Gordons, that there are no women and children to hand. Yeah. There is a space. He gets in. When that lifeboat leaves, Tom, there are six empty spaces.
可能是，就像达夫·戈登夫妇一样，当时手边没有妇女和儿童。是的。有一个空位。他上去了。当那艘救生艇离开时，汤姆，有六个空位。
He is not denying somebody else a space. No. So there is room. There is absolutely room. Well, so the British report on the tragedy says, had he not jumped in, he would merely have added one more life, namely his own, to the number of those lost. but this is something that we will be looking at in our final episode when we look at the reactions to it is the judgments on ismay in the film i mean we'll talk about this in more depth next time but in the film the moment when he does this i mean he's been shown as a pretty
他并没有剥夺别人的空间。不。所以有空间。绝对有空间。嗯，所以关于这场悲剧的英国报告说，如果他没有跳上去，他只会多增加一条生命，即他自己的生命，到那些遇难者的名单中。但这将是我们最后一集要探讨的内容，当我们审视对它的反应时，就是对伊斯梅的评判。在电影中，我是说，我们下次会更深入地讨论这一点，但在电影中，他做这件事的那一刻，我是说，他一直被表现为一个相当
despicable character hasn't he throughout the film he. In every drama, he's shown as a terrible man. And he looks so shifty and furtive. In his slippers and his dressing gown. And he slips onto the boat at the last minute. Yeah. But, I mean, personally,
卑鄙的角色，不是吗，在整部电影中。在每一部剧中，他都被表现为一个可怕的人。他看起来那么鬼鬼祟祟、偷偷摸摸。穿着拖鞋和睡袍。他在最后一刻溜上了船。是的。但是，我是说，就个人而言，
I think that is unbelievably harsh. I mean, he did the right thing. Dominic, we will discuss this in due course. Okay. But it doesn't help, Ismay, does it,
我认为这令人难以置信地严厉。我是说，他做了正确的事。多米尼克，我们会在适当的时候讨论这个问题。好的。但这并没有帮助伊斯梅，不是吗，
that people who are considerably more famous and celebrated and richer than him do stay? And I suppose the richest of them all is Captain Jack Astor. Yes. So about 1.55 now. So we're an hour and 15 minutes after they hit the lifeboat. Remember, Thomas Andrews had said it would sink in two hours. So they're more than halfway through that time and they're really running out of lifeboats now so this is the last big one lifeboat four port side light dollar is filling it there's been a bit of faffing around with what deck it's going to go from we don't need to necessarily go into that light dollar is saying come on come on come on aster is standing there
那些比他更出名、更受赞誉、更富有的人却留下了？我想他们中最富有的是杰克·阿斯特船长。是的。所以现在大约是1点55分。所以我们在他们撞上冰山后1小时15分钟。记住，托马斯·安德鲁斯曾说它会在两小时内沉没。所以他们已经过了那个时间的一半多，他们现在真的快没救生艇了。所以这是最后一艘大船，4号救生艇，左舷，莱托勒正在装载它。关于它要从哪层甲板放下，有一些折腾，我们不一定需要深入讨论。莱托勒说，快点，快点，快点。阿斯特站在那里
with his child bride pregnant child bride she gets in says to her, please get in to please me. And then he says in this sort of quiet, courteous way to Lightoller, is there any chance I could get in with my pregnant wife? And Lightoller says, no, sir. No men are allowed in these boats until the women are loaded first. So he's holding fast to that commitment. And Aster is clearly not happy and he says to his wife the sea is calm you'll be all right you're in good hands i'll meet you in the morning and he
和他的童养媳，怀孕的童养媳。她上去了，他对她说，请上去，为了我。然后他以那种安静、礼貌的方式对莱托勒说，我有没有可能和怀孕的妻子一起上去？莱托勒说，不，先生。在妇女先上船之前，不允许任何男人上这些船。所以他坚持那个承诺。阿斯特显然不高兴，他对妻子说，海面很平静，你会没事的，你会得到很好的照顾，我早上会见到你。他
gives his gloves to her and then steps back from the rail and salutes her and then the lifeboat is away yeah so there's one more lifeboat they managed to get away, collapsible D, one of these lifeboats with collapsible sides. And so now everyone on the ship, there are no lifeboats left. No. So what are you to do? So people start jumping, don't they? They do. Yeah, people huddle in their groups. So Aster is with a guy called John Thayer and he's with George Widener. With his book.
把手套给了她，然后从栏杆边退后，向她敬礼，然后救生艇就离开了。是的，所以还有最后一艘救生艇，他们设法让它离开了，D号折叠艇，这些带有折叠侧面的救生艇之一。所以现在船上的每个人，没有救生艇了。不。那你该怎么办？所以人们开始跳船，不是吗？他们确实跳了。是的，人们聚在一起。所以阿斯特和一个叫约翰·塞耶的人在一起，他和乔治·怀德纳在一起。带着他的书。
Very close to them is a guy called Archie butt who we talked about before president taft's military advisor um some people have started jumping light taller and some of the other crew guys are trying to get down two more collapsible boats which were fastened to the roof of the officer's quarters this happens in the film doesn't it they're trying to get them onto the deck yeah but it's at that point when more and more waves are rushing onto the deck. The ship is beginning to plunge. Lightotter describes, he says, the sea came rolling up in a wave over the steel-fronted bridge along the deck below us, washing the people back in a dreadful huddled mass. He himself, I mean, his story of survival is one of the most famous stories. He, at this point jumps off
离他们很近的是一个叫阿奇·巴特的人，我们之前谈过，塔夫脱总统的军事顾问。嗯，有些人开始跳船。莱托勒和其他一些船员正试图放下另外两艘折叠艇，它们被固定在军官宿舍的屋顶上。这在电影中发生了，不是吗？他们正试图把它们弄到甲板上。是的，但就在那时，越来越多的海浪冲上甲板。船开始下沉。莱托勒描述说，他说，海水卷起一股浪潮，越过钢制的舰桥，沿着我们下方的甲板，把人们冲回一团可怕的拥挤的人群中。他自己，我是说，他的生存故事是最著名的故事之一。他在这一点上跳下了
the boat he says striking the water was like a thousand knives being driven into one's body and for a few moments i completely lost grip of myself we'll come to this but you cannot exaggerate how cold that water is i mean that water is so cold it will kill you well there's the um again this is quoted in the film it's given to jack when he's trying to persuade rose not to jump in and says that if you do jump in, the cold is like kind of like a thousand daggers cutting you to pieces. Oh, right. Same line. Of course. Yeah. And that's lifted. But I mean, it is unbelievably cold. You're going to have about 20, 20 minutes. Yes. Before you die of hypothermia.
船，他说，撞击水面就像一千把刀刺进身体，有那么几分钟，我完全失去了对自己的控制。我们会谈到这一点，但你无法夸大那水有多冷。我是说那水太冷了，它会杀了你。嗯，那个，同样，这在电影中被引用了，当杰克试图说服罗斯不要跳下去时，他说如果你跳下去，寒冷就像一千把匕首把你切成碎片。哦，对。同一句台词。当然。是的。那是借用的。但我是说，它冷得令人难以置信。你大约有20分钟。是的。在死于体温过低之前。
But he, Lightoller, is dragged into this shaft with a wire grating on the ship. And the water is pouring in and he's being dragged and dragged into it and he would have died had it not been for the fact that basically at that point the ship belches out some hot air and sort of blows him up to the surface of the ocean out of the shaft and he's able to scramble onto one of the collapsibles collapsible b which has been washed away from the ship. And this is probably the moment that Captain Smith dies, whether on the bridge or not, but probably on the bridge.
但他，莱托勒，被拖进了船上的一个带有金属网的竖井里。水涌了进来，他被拖啊拖，如果不是因为在那一点上船喷出了一些热空气，把他吹到了海面上，出了竖井，他本会死的。他能够爬上一艘折叠艇，B号折叠艇，它被从船上冲走了。这可能是史密斯船长死亡的时刻，无论是在舰桥上还是其他地方，但很可能是在舰桥上。
Yeah. I can't believe, Tom, I can't believe you're pouring scorn on him saying, be British, boys, be British. Well, we know that that was made up. We know that was made up. Because nobody saw him die. There were no reports of him dying. Except suddenly they started being manufactured. I think it's sad to see the podcast descend
是的。我不敢相信，汤姆，我不敢相信你在嘲笑他，说“做个英国人，小伙子们，做个英国人”。嗯，我们知道那是编造的。我们知道那是编造的。因为没人看到他死。没有关于他死亡的报道。除了突然间它们开始被制造出来。我觉得看到播客陷入
into such anti, you know, Britain-hating cynicism. Why do I hate Britain? Yeah, exactly. Yes. So the funnel collapses, and that happens two hours and 25 minutes after hitting the iceberg. It crashes downwards.
这种反，你知道，仇视英国的愤世嫉俗中，很可悲。为什么我仇视英国？是的，确实。是的。所以烟囱倒塌了，那发生在撞上冰山后2小时25分钟。它向下坠落。
It splinters the deck. It hits the sea with a massive, great, thunderous crash. The camera and film captures this very well, doesn't it? The sheer horror and spectacle, actually, of this colossal edifice toppling and smashing. And smashing people who are underneath it, who are already in the water. Exactly. And one of the things interesting about the survivors on the lifeboats who are watching it, again and again, they come up with the same metaphor. So Beasley, who we've talked about, he compares it to a stricken animal, this thing, the ship. And then Violet Jessop, who is one of the stewards who we quoted earlier, who's got into one of the lifeboats. One of the huge funnels toppled off like a cardboard model,
它把甲板砸碎了。它以巨大的、雷鸣般的撞击声撞击海面。电影镜头捕捉得很好，不是吗？这个巨大的建筑倒塌和粉碎的纯粹恐怖和壮观。并粉碎了在它下面的人，那些已经在水里的人。没错。关于在救生艇上观看这一幕的幸存者，有趣的一点是，他们一次又一次地用同一个比喻。所以比斯利，我们谈过他，他把它比作一只受惊的动物，这个东西，这艘船。然后维奥莱特·杰索普，我们之前引用的乘务员之一，她上了其中一艘救生艇。巨大的烟囱像纸板模型一样倒塌，
falling into the sea with a fearful roar. A few cries came to us across the water, then silence as the ship seemed to write herself like a hurt animal with a broken back. So the sense of it as a living creature that is in its death throes, really, really powerful. And,
带着可怕的咆哮声落入海中。几声哭喊声穿过水面传到我们这里，然后是寂静，因为船似乎像一只脊椎骨折的受伤动物一样把自己扶正了。所以那种它是一个处于垂死挣扎中的生物的感觉，真的，真的非常强大。而且，
you know, the visuals of it are incredible. The lights flickering, dimming, flickering again. And then at 2.20, going out two hours and 40 minutes after the iceberg had been glimpsed by the lookout. So Ismay... He can't bear to look. He sits with his back to it. Some people look.
你知道，它的视觉效果令人难以置信。灯光闪烁、变暗、再次闪烁。然后在2点20分，在瞭望员瞥见冰山2小时40分钟后熄灭了。所以伊斯梅……他无法忍受去看。他背对着它坐着。有些人看了。
Lady Duff Gordon, she sees the lights being extinguished. She says, I turned shudderingly away. Then I forced myself to look again, yet another row of lights had disappeared. Then her husband cries out, my God, she's going.
达夫·戈登夫人，她看到灯光熄灭。她说，我颤抖着转过身去。然后我强迫自己再看一眼，又一排灯光消失了。然后她的丈夫大喊，我的上帝，它要沉了。
And then what they all describe... It's the most extraordinary moment, isn't it? Yeah. I mean, the bit that for me when i saw the film traumatized me so much that i couldn't bring myself to watch it again until a few days ago tom i'll read what light hola says the huge ship slowly but surely reared herself on end and brought rudder and propellers clear of the water till at last she assumed an absolutely perpendicular position in this amazing attitude she remained for the space of half a minute then with impressive majesty and ever-increasing momentum she silently took her last tragic dive
然后他们所描述的一切……那是最非凡的时刻，不是吗？是的。我的意思是，当我看到电影里那一段时，我受到了极大的创伤，以至于直到几天前我才敢再看一遍。汤姆，我来读一下莱特·霍拉（Lightoller）是怎么说的：这艘巨轮缓慢而坚定地竖起船尾，将舵和螺旋桨抬离水面，直到最后它呈现出完全垂直的姿态。它以这种惊人的姿态保持了半分钟，然后带着令人印象深刻的庄严和不断增加的动量，静静地进行了最后一次悲剧性的下潜。
to seek a final resting place in the unfathomable depths of the cold gray sea and um edith russell who's a fashion reporter who'd been in first class and got on one of the boats compares watching it to the collapse of a skyscraper and i think anyone who's seen the film even if you hate the film it's an incredible moment there's the bit where jack and rose are clinging to the very top of it and they're next to a bloke who drops off and his corpse bounces off the propeller yeah and into the sea and then it just plunges down deep into the water i mean an amazing amazing moment it is it's incredible But the thing that most people remember, actually, funnily enough, is not so much the spectacle
去寻找它在冰冷灰暗的大海深处那最终的安息之所。嗯，埃迪丝·拉塞尔（Edith Russell）是一位时尚记者，她当时在头等舱，并登上了其中一艘救生艇，她将这一幕比作摩天大楼的倒塌。我想任何看过这部电影的人，即使你讨厌这部电影，也会觉得这是一个令人难以置信的时刻。电影里有杰克和露丝紧紧抓住船尾最高处的那一段，他们旁边的一个人掉了下去，尸体撞在螺旋桨上，然后掉进海里，接着船身就沉入了深水中。我的意思是，这是一个令人惊叹的时刻。确实，这太不可思议了。但有趣的是，大多数人真正记住的并不是那种场面，
as it's the sound. It's the sound. Because we started this with the sound of the marbles or the grinding of the iceberg just going along the side. And people say, Lady Duff Gordon,
而是声音。是那种声音。因为我们开头提到了弹珠的声音，或者是冰山沿着船侧摩擦的声音。人们说，达夫·戈登夫人（Lady Duff Gordon），
an indescribable clamour. Lots of people use the word clamour because what happens is, you see, the people who die don't drown. They have life jackets on. White life jackets. By and large, they die of the cold and it takes them 15 to 20 minutes to die.
一种难以形容的喧嚣。很多人用了“喧嚣”这个词，因为发生的事情是这样的：那些死去的人并没有淹死。他们穿着救生衣，白色的救生衣。总的来说，他们是死于寒冷，而这个过程需要15到20分钟。
And all the lifeboats were around them. So people can hear the howling and crying and sort of the sound of it. Jack Thayer, one of the survivors he calls it a continuous wailing chant from the 1500 people in the water all around us it sounded like locusts on a midsummer night in the woods in pennsylvania now you mentioned the goldsmith family tom so frank goldsmith and his son frankie frankie the little boy is nine years old and his mother, they're on their lifeboat. His mother, she kind of cuddles him so that he won't see the horror. But he hears it, of course. He hears the howling.
当时所有的救生艇都在他们周围。所以人们能听到那种哀号和哭喊声，以及那种声音。幸存者之一杰克·塞耶（Jack Thayer）称之为“来自水中1500人的持续不断的哀号声，听起来就像宾夕法尼亚州仲夏夜树林里的蝗虫声”。现在你提到了戈德史密斯（Goldsmith）一家，汤姆。弗兰克·戈德史密斯和他的儿子弗兰基，弗兰基是个九岁的小男孩，他和母亲在救生艇上。母亲紧紧抱着他，不让他看到那恐怖的一幕。但当然，他听到了。他听到了那种哀号。
And later on, when he's growing up, he lives near the Detroit Tigers baseball stadium. He drove a milk cart. And whenever the team hit a home run, he would say, he had this moment of terror because the roar of the crowd always, always brought back the sound of the 1500 people freezing to death out there in the Atlantic. So people may be wondering, well, there are all these lifeboats with empty places. Why are they not going back to rescue people who've fallen into the sea? Some of them want to.
后来，当他长大后，他住在底特律老虎队棒球场附近。他曾是一名送奶工。每当球队打出本垒打时，他都会说，他会感到一阵恐惧，因为人群的欢呼声总是、总是让他想起大西洋上那1500人在寒冷中死去的哀号声。所以人们可能会想，救生艇上还有空位，为什么他们不回去营救那些落水的人呢？有些人是想回去的。
Some of them do want to, don't they? Yeah. And the answer is that they're afraid that if they go back, they will get capsized and they will all die.
有些人确实想回去，不是吗？是的。答案是他们担心如果回去，救生艇会倾覆，所有人都会丧命。
They will. And in fact, there is only one lifeboat that goes back, and that's lifeboat 14, commanded by a man called Harold Lowe, who in the film
他们会的。事实上，只有一艘救生艇回去了，那就是14号救生艇，由一个叫哈罗德·洛（Harold Lowe）的人指挥，他在电影中
is played by Owen Gruffydd. Oh, yes. And they go back, basically, once the dying people, in his words, have been thinned out. It's a kind of horrible way of putting it. He says it would not have been wise or safe to have gone there before because a whole lot of us would have been swamped and then nobody would have been saved. And so he goes through, but they find only four men alive. And one of them is one of the Chinese firemen, a man called Fang Lang,
由欧文·格鲁福德（Ioan Gruffudd）饰演。哦，是的。基本上，当那些垂死的人，用他的话说是“被稀释”之后，他们才回去。这是一种很可怕的说法。他说，在那之前回去是不明智也不安全的，因为我们很多人会被淹没，那样就没人能获救了。所以他回去了，但他们只发现了四名幸存者。其中一个是名叫方朗（Fang Lang）的中国籍司炉工，
who is found clinging to a door, which is, of course, how Rose survives in the film. Yeah, of course, of course. So one story just to end on this, I think, to give you a sense of the, if we haven't had enough horror. On Collapsible A, there was only one woman, only one woman survivor,
他被发现时正紧紧抓住一扇门，这当然就是电影中露丝获救的方式。是的，当然，当然。所以，为了结束这个话题，我想讲一个故事，如果你觉得恐怖还不够的话。在A号折叠艇上，只有一名女性幸存者，
and she's called Rhoda Abbott. And she was a seamstress from Buckinghamshire who had moved to rhode island and she was married to a boxer there in rhode island and then she'd come back to england with her sons who were called ross moore and eugene but they actually didn't really like england so she decided she'd take them back to north america and she's going back to North America. And they don't make it onto a lifeboat initially. And she stays because she won't leave her boys. So she stays on the ship.
她叫罗达·阿博特（Rhoda Abbott）。她是一位来自白金汉郡的裁缝，曾搬到罗德岛，并在那里嫁给了一位拳击手。后来她带着儿子罗斯·摩尔（Ross Moore）和尤金（Eugene）回到了英国，但他们其实并不喜欢英国，所以她决定带他们回北美。她正准备回北美。起初他们没能登上救生艇。她留了下来，因为她不愿离开她的孩子们。所以她留在了船上。
The ship plunges. The boys shove her into collapsible A and then they're off into the ocean. And the two boys, 16 and 13, are hanging on to the edge of the collapsible boat while her mother is in the boat. But as Richard Davenport Hines says in his book, young men die more quickly in freezing temperatures because they have a lower percentage of body fat,
船身下沉。孩子们把她推上了A号折叠艇，然后他们就掉进了海里。两个男孩，16岁和13岁，紧紧抓住折叠艇的边缘，而他们的母亲就在船上。但正如理查德·达文波特-海恩斯（Richard Davenport-Hines）在他的书中所说，年轻人在极寒天气下死得更快，因为他们的体脂率较低，
but also because they tend to get more, I mean, excited as it were. And that means they go more quickly into shock. And so the two boys are holding the edge of this boat and their mother is looking on and one by one, they slip away into the sea with her watching. And there is nothing she can do about it. And as Davenport Hines says, it must have felt unbelievable. Few women can have ever suffered as she did so there you go well to coin a phrase a night to remember we will be back imminently with our final episode where we will look at the aftermath of the titanic the way that it's been understood the myths that have grown around it the metaphors that have been projected onto it we'll look at the film but of
而且他们往往更容易，怎么说呢，情绪激动。这意味着他们会更快地陷入休克。所以两个男孩抓着船的边缘，他们的母亲看着，一个接一个，他们滑入海中，而她只能眼睁睁地看着。她无能为力。正如达文波特-海恩斯所说，这一定让人感到难以置信。很少有女性像她那样遭受过如此的痛苦。好了，借用一句名言，“难忘之夜”。我们很快会回来进行最后一集，我们将回顾泰坦尼克号的余波，人们对它的理解，围绕它产生的神话，以及投射在它身上的隐喻。我们将讨论这部电影，但当然，
course if you don't want to wait for that, if you, rather than hanging around on the deck of the Titanic, you want to get in a lifeboat, you can do that by going to therestishistory.com and you will be able to have that episode right away. But for now, bye-bye. Bye-bye.
如果你不想等待，如果你不想在泰坦尼克号的甲板上徘徊，而是想坐上救生艇，你可以访问therestishistory.com，你就可以立即收听那一集。但现在，再见。再见。
I'm Marina Hyde and I'm Richard Osman and together we host The Rest Is Entertainment it's your weekly fix of entertainment news reviews splash of showbiz gossip and on our Q&A
我是玛丽娜·海德（Marina Hyde），我是理查德·奥斯曼（Richard Osman），我们共同主持《余下的就是娱乐》（The Rest Is Entertainment）。这是你每周获取娱乐新闻、评论和一点点演艺圈八卦的地方，在我们的问答环节，
we pull back the curtain on entertainment and we tell you how it all works we have just launched our members club if you want ad free listening bonus episodes and early access to live tickets head to therestisentertain live tickets, head to therestisentertainment.com. That's therestisentertainment.com. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
我们揭开娱乐界的幕布，告诉你这一切是如何运作的。我们刚刚推出了会员俱乐部，如果你想要无广告收听、额外剧集以及提前购买现场演出门票，请前往therestisentertainment.com。网址是therestisentertainment.com。本集目前还没有评论。点击转录中的任何句子即可发表评论。